SENATE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
THE SELECT THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON WOMEN WORK AND FAMILIES CO
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS THE
TITLE OF THIS HEARING IS THE
PINK TAX. HOW GENDER BASED
PRICING DISCRIMINATION
UNDERMINES WOMEN'S ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY AND WHAT TO DO
ABOUT IT. I WANT TO WELCOME YOU
ALL IN MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
DíAS AS WELL I'M GRATEFUL TO
THOSE OF YOU HERE IN THE
AUDIENCE AND THOSE OF YOU ON
THE DíAS ATTENDING- THIS IS AS
I MENTIONED A JOINT HEARING AND
THERE WILL BE I THINK PEOPLE
JOINING US ON LINE. WHICH IS.
KIND OF HARD FOR ALL FOLKS LIKE
ME WERE USED TO COUNTING HEADS-
BUT- I'M GOING TO ASSUME THAT
THERE. ARE A NUMBER OF PEOPLE
OUT THERE- WHO ARE ALSO
INTERESTED IN THIS ISSUE AND
ONE WELCOME THEM AS WELL- OUR
FIRST WITNESS THE HONORABLE
CONGRESSWOMAN JACKIE SPEAR HAS
I KNOW A FLIGHT COMING UP WITH
AND A HARD STOP IN. A BIT- BUT
I AM DELIGHTED THAT SHE HAS
AGREED TO BE HERE TODAY AND TO
SHARE WITH US SHE SORT OF THE-
MOTHER OF. EQUALITY IN. A
GENDER PRICING HAVING. SERVED
IN THIS BODY HE FOR MANY YEARS
AND HAVING BROUGHT THE FIRST
BILL. TO BAN DISCRIMINATION IN
THE BASIS ON THE BASIS OF
GENDER FOR SERVICES. AND THAT
WAS I THINK IN NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR- SO FAST FORWARD HERE WE
ARE TWENTY FIVE YEARS LATER SHE
LOOKS NO DIFFERENT AND I'M VERY
JEALOUS BUT- WE HAVEN'T REALLY
MOVED TO AS FAR. BEYOND THAT
LEVEL OF DISCRIMINATION AS WE
MUST AND SO WITH YOUR DAY TODAY
TO TAKE A DEEP DIVE INTO THIS
ISSUE- IT'S- GENDER BASED
PRICING DISCRIMINATION
SOMETIMES CALLED THE PINK TAX I
WANT TO BE CLEAR. THIS IS NOT A
TAX COLLECTED BY GOVERNMENT
THIS IS A TAX COLLECTED BY
COMPANIES. TO ADD TO THEIR
PROFIT MARGIN AT THE EXPENSE OF
WOMEN AND FAMILIES IT'S A
PRACTICE OF CHARGING HIGHER
PRICES FOR GOODS AND SERVICES
THAT ARE MARKETED TO WOMEN.
WHEN THE SAME ESSENTIAL PRODUCT
OR SERVICES ARE SOLD LESS A TWO
MAN. SO THIS IS OBVIOUSLY
SOMETHING OF CONCERN TO THOSE
OF US WHO ARE OUT THERE IN THE
MARKETPLACE- BUYING PRODUCTS
FOR OURSELVES OR OUR CHILDREN.
OR FAMILIES AND- BASICALLY JUST
THE BOTTOM LINE IS NOT ONLY IS
IT BAD ECONOMICALLY BUT IT'S
WRONG JUST SIMPLY WRONG. AND IT
SYSTEMATICALLY DEPRIVED WOMEN
OF EQUAL EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY. AND ALSO
PSYCHOLOGICALLY A WASH WE'D BE
PAYING MORE FOR RAZORS THAT ARE
PINK THE MEN PAY FOR THE VERY
SAME RAZOR THAT IS BLACK. OR
SOME OTHER COLOR WHY SHOULD
CHILDREN AS WE HAVE HERE IS AN
EXAMPLE OF TO TEDDY BEARS WE OF
ALL INSPECTED THEM VERY
CAREFULLY THEY ARE EXACTLY THE
SAME. EXCEPT AS TO COLOR. THE
PINK ONE IS TWO DOLLARS MORE
THAN THE BLUE ONE. WHY IS THAT.
THERE IS NO DECENT EXPLANATION
FOR THAT COM IF THERE IS WE'RE
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO HEAR IT BUT
THE EXPLANATION REALLY
OBVIOUSLY IS MORE BASED UPON.
THE PERCEPTION THAT WOMEN ARE
PREPARED TO AND WILLING TO PAY
MORE FOR A PRODUCT OF THAT IS
MARKETED TO THEM IN IN A COLOR
THAT WOMEN AND CHILDREN- GIRLS
IN PARTICULAR TEND TO PREFER-
SO WE ARE GOING TO LOOK INTO
THIS. WE SHOULD NOT BE
TOLERATING THE CIRCUMSTANCE WE
DO HAVE WITNESSES WHO ARE GOING
TO COME HOPEFULLY AND TELL US-
THE PERSPECTIVE FROM THE
MANUFACTURERS POINT OF VIEW OR
THE- DISTRIBUTOR THE RETAILERS
POINT OF VIEW AND- I YOU KNOW
THAT WE'RE ALL VERY INTERESTED
TO HEAR. THAT PERSPECTIVE AS
WELL. A WE'RE HERE WE A THE
PIONEER AND TIRELESS WORKER ON
THIS ISSUE CONGRESSWOMAN.
JACKIE SPEAR- SHE WILL SHARE
WITH US- THE- HISTORY LITTLE
BIT OF THE HISTORY AND THEN
SHE'S ALSO BRING A SIMILAR
BILL. IN CONGRESS- SO THAT WE
CAN- HOPEFULLY WORK TOGETHER
CALIFORNIA COURSES BEEN IN THE
LEAD IN A NUMBER OF GENDER.
DISCRIMINATION LEGISLATION TO
OFFSET THIS KIND OF
UNACCEPTABLE- VIOLATIVE
BEHAVIOR. AND LOOK FORWARD TO
HER TESTIMONY SO WITHOUT
FURTHER DO GIVEN THE FACT THAT
YOU DO HAVE. A TIME CONSTRAINTS
WILL HEAR FROM A CONGRESSWOMAN
SPEAR AND THEN OPEN IT UP FOR
SOME QUESTIONS UNLESS ANYONE
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE AN OPENING
STATEMENT AT THIS TIME. THE
THREE BODY OKAY GREAT.
CONGRESSMAN SPEAR THE FLOOR IS
YOURS MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AT THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR
BEFORE YOU A SPECIAL SHOUT OUT
TO MY GOOD FRIEND AND COLLEAGUE
SENATOR HILL- FOR HAVING THE
BRILLIANCE TO RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF WOMEN AND
FAMILIES- AND TO SERVE ON THIS
COMMITTEE AND TO ALL THE OTHER
MEMBERS IT'S GREAT TO BE HERE
IT'S GREAT TO I FEEL LIKE I'M
HOME AGAIN IT. SPENT EIGHTEEN
YEARS OF MY LIFE HERE SO IT'S
REALLY GREAT TO BE BACK MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU FOR THE
INCREDIBLE LEADERSHIP YOU'VE
SHOWN A IN THIS ISSUE AREA
AMONG MANY OTHERS THE BILL THAT
YOU'VE INTRODUCED SB EIGHT
FIFTY WHAT'S THE NUMBER. SEVEN
EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT SEVENTY
THREE I NEED SOME HELP TO
REMIND ME I'M NOT GOOD AT THE
NUMBERS EITHER EIGHT SEVENTY
THREE WHOLE HEARTEDLY ENDORSED
AND ENCOURAGE THE PASSAGE OF A
I HAVE A SIMILAR BILL ON THE
FEDERAL LEVEL THIS REALLY GO
BACK TO NINETEEN NINETY FOUR IT
PASSABLE EVEN NINETY NINETY SIX
BILL I CARRIED. TO DRAW
ATTENTION FACT THAT SERVICES IN
THE STATE WERE BEING BIASED NOT
ON THE AMOUNT OF TIME IT TAKES
TO PROVIDE THE SERVICE BUT I
WHETHER YOU MAY OR FEMALE. SO
WE WENT OUT OF A BAY CAMPAIGN.
TAKING WHITE OXFORD SHIRT. TO
THE DRY CLEANER. EXACTLY THE
SAME. THAT IF IT WAS A WOMAN
SURE IT IT WAS TWO OR THREE
DOLLARS MORE. TO LAUNDER THAN A
MAN'S SHIRT- AGAIN- WITH HAIR
RECENTLY YOU MAY HAVE HEARD OF
THE DUST UP THAT OCCURRED WHEN
ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES SO I PAID
EIGHTY DOLLARS FOR A HAIR CUT.
AND SHE WAS MOCKED BY FORMER
GOVERNOR SCOTT WALKER WHO WENT
IN AND SHOW THAT HE HAD PAID
ONLY TWENTY SIX DOLLARS FOR THE
HAIR CUT WELL- WHAT WE
RECOGNIZE WAY BACK IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES IS THAT WE
SHOULD BE BASING THIS ON GENDER
BUT ON THE AMOUNT OF TIME IT
TAKES. TO LAUNDER A SHIRT OR
CUT HAIR OR DO TAILORING SO THE
BILL PASSED BECAME LAW. AND
PROVIDES FOR PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION. DURING THE COURSE OF
THAT LEGISLATION I HAVE THE
ASSEMBLY OFFICE OF RESEARCH. DO
I A PROJECT TO EVALUATE HOW
MUCH IS IT REALLY COSTING WOMEN
IN CALIFORNIA THIS IS NINETEEN.
NINETY FOUR TO NINETEEN NINETY
SIX- AND THEY CAME BACK WITH A
FIGURE OF THIRTEEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY ONE DOLLARS MORE PER YEAR.
FOR WOMEN JUST IN TERMS OF
SERVICES THAT THEY WOULD- BE
PAYING. AND YOU COUPLE THAT
WITH THE FACT THAT WOMEN ARE
MAKING LESS. THAN MEN. THE WAGE
GAP IS STILL ABOUT EIGHTY TWO
CENTS FOR EVERY DOLLAR EARNED
BY MEN IT'S MUCH WORSE FOR
WOMEN OF COLOR- AND YOU IT
COUPLE THOSE TWO TOGETHER AND
IT'S JUST LIKE THE PERFECT
STORM OF VIOLATION AT THE NEW
YORK CITY DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFAIRS IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN. DID A SURVEY OF
PRODUCTS AND FOUND THAT ON
AVERAGE WOMEN WERE PAYING- 13%
MORE. NOW SO THEN I EMBARKED ON
DOING THIS ON A FEDERAL LEVEL
AND LAST SUMMER MICE STUDENT
INTERNS ALL WERE CHARGED WITH
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF GOING
ONLINE. AND LOOKING AT GOODS.
THAT WERE REFERENCES BOY GIRL
MAN WOMAN AND LOOK AT
DIFFERENTIALS SO FOR INSTANCE
THESE TEDDY BEARS WERE ON A BIG
BOX WEBSITE. THEY HAD THE
AUDACITY TO CHARGE 22% MORE FOR
THE PINK TEDDY BEAR THEN THE
BLUE TEDDY BEAR. IF YOU LOOK AT
THE RAZORS OVER HERE- THE
RAZORS- A DIFFICULT SHIP
RAZORS. LOU AND PAYING. EIGHT
FIFTY NINE TO ELEVEN NINETY
NINE THAT'S A- 13% INCREASE FOR
THE RAZORS- AND THEN IF YOU
LOOK AT THESE SHOES. DOLLARS
THESE ARE SIXTY DOLLARS THAT IS
A DIFFERENTIAL OF 33% IN THERE
EXACTLY THE SAME DOWN TO THE
SOLES ON THE BOTTOM. CUSTOMER
SURE- SERGEANT WE HAVE SERGEANT
HEALTH. SOUTH IT'S REAL MONEY
AND WHEN YOU RECOGNIZE THAT
WOMEN OVER THEIR LIFETIME
BECAUSE OF THE PAY GAP ALONE.
ARE LOSING ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN DISPOSABLE
INCOME IT'S REALLY SERIOUS SO-
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
ADDRESS THIS I GUESS THAT THE
REAL TOPPER WAS LAST WEEK IN
TENNESSEE. WHERE TENNESSEE WAS
GOING TO OFFER A TAX HOLIDAY
FOR THE PURCHASE OF CARS AND
APPLIANCES AND THEY HAD-
CONTEMPLATED WHETHER OR NOT
THEY WOULD INCLUDE TAMPONS. AND
THEN THEY DECIDED NOT TO
INCLUDE TAMPONS BECAUSE IT
WOULD LOSE SO MUCH REVENUE TO
THE STATE OR THERE'D BE A RUN
ON TAMPONS NOW IF THAT'S NOT
CITY IS DISCRIMINATION I DON'T
KNOW WHAT IS SO. IT'S THERE M.
WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO FIX
THAT- IN MY WORK IN WASHINGTON.
WE HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL VERY
RECENTLY AND GETTING THE
DEADLINE STRICKEN FROM THE
EQUAL RIGHTS AMENDMENT IT'S NOW
BEEN PASSED BY THIRTY EIGHT
STATES. SO IT SHOULD BECOME
PART OF OUR CONSTITUTION- IT
NOW IS- SITTING IN THE SENATE
WHERE WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
SOMEHOW KNOWLEDGE THE PRESIDENT
THE SENATE TO TAKE IT OUT
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE REQUISITE
NUMBER OF VOTES TO PASS IT. IF
GENDER DISCRIMINATION WERE
PROHIBITED IN THE CONSTITUTION
ALL OF THESE CASES. WOULD BE
DEALT WITH BECAUSE YOU COULD
BRING AN ACTION STATING THAT IT
WAS UNCONSTITUTIONAL IT IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL IT'S
DISCRIMINATORY AND IT'S TIME
FOR US TO ADDRESS IT ON EVERY
LEVEL BUT WOMEN ARE THE BIG.
CONSUMERS OF PRODUCTS THEY
PURCHASE ABOUT 7280% OF ALL
CONSUMABLE PRODUCTS. IN THE
COUNTRY SO- WE SHOULD.
RECOGNIZE THAT BECAUSE THEY
HAVE THE PURCHASING POWER THEY
ALSO HAVE THE POWER TO SAY THIS
KIND OF DISCRIMINATION SHOULD
NOT CONTINUE- AND I THINK WITH
THAT MISSY FIVE AREA AND
THOUGHTS THAT I WANTED TO SHARE
WITH YOU. YOU KNOW THAT WE
OFTEN SAY THAT THAT THIS KIND
OF DISCRIMINATION GOES ON FROM
CRADLE TO GRAVE AND I DIDN'T
BRING THE SAMPLES BECAUSE THEY
WERE A LITTLE BULKY FROM
WASHINGTON BUT- ADULT DIAPERS
HE WENT INTO A WALGREENS. I
DON'T THIS WAS MAYBE A FEW
MONTHS AGO MAYBE THEY'VE
CHANGED THEIR THEIR PRICING BUT
IF YOU BOUGHT A WOMAN'S ADULT
DIAPERS. THEY WERE THE SAME
PRICE AS THE MAN THE DAHLE
DIAPERS EXCEPT YOU GOT FOUR
DIAPERS LESS. THEN THE MEN'S
ADULT DIAPERS SO IT IS FROM
CRADLE TO GRAVE AND IT'S TIME
FOR US TO FIX IT WITH THAT
MADAM CHAIR I WILL FEEL THE
REST OF MY TIME THANK YOU
SENATOR SPEAR. NOW IF THERE
QUESTIONS I HAVE A FEW BUT IF
ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO START
I THINK THAT'S QUITE AN
INTERESTING VISUAL ALSO THE NEW
YORK- THE CITY OF NEW YORK DID
A RATHER LENGTHY STUDY OF SOME
EIGHT HUNDRED PRODUCTS AND THEY
DISCOVERED NOT ONLY WERE
ONESIES MORE EXPENSIVE IF THEY
WERE IN PINK THEN IF THEY WERE
IN NON PINK BUT EVEN CANES FOR
OUR SENIORS WOMEN PAY MORE FOR
CAIN. THEY'LL THEORETICALLY WE
ARE SHORTER I IT'S JUST IT'S
MIND BOGGLING THAT THAT THAT IS
THE CASE AND OF COURSE- THE YOU
KNOW I GUESS TO TERRY'S WELL
YOU CAN GET AWAY WITH THE YOU
CAN DO IT- BUT THAT'S WHY WE
HEAR SO I DID HAVEA COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS FOR YOU- HOW DO YOU-
HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THOSE YOU
MENTIONED THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION AND OF COURSE IN
CALIFORNIA AS YOU WELL KNOW AS
WELL AS ANYONE- THIS THE
LEGISLATION THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON IN THIS AREA. IS
UNDER THE UNDER THE CIVIL
RIGHTS ACT AND THE ON RESERVE A
RIGHT CHECK WHICH HAS BEEN IN
FORCE IN EFFECT SINCE NINETEEN
FIFTY NINE CALLS FOR A PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION- AFTER YOU GOT
YOUR BILL PASSED ON SERVICES
DID WE SEE ANY KIND OF A
FLOODGATE OF LITIGATION WE HEAR
THIS ALL THE TIME BUT FRIVOLOUS
LAWSUITS AND SO FORTH IF YOU
GIVE PEOPLE THE ABILITY TO. AND
FOR THEIR DID DID YOU SEE. DID
WE SEE CA OF. OPEN AS FAR AS
THE WAS. I DON'T THINK THERE'S
BEEN ONE ACTION BROUGHT. IN
COURT IN CALIFORNIA. BASED ON
THE SERVICES ANTI
DISCRIMINATION LAW SO THERE IS
NO FLOOD GATE OF CASES THAT
HAVE BEEN BROUGHT FORTH BUT WE
DO KNOW THERE'S PLENTY OF
VIOLATIONS OF THE LAW THAT.
MANY SMALL BUSINESSES ARE STILL.
DISTINGUISHING AND
DISCRIMINATING BASED ON GENDER
IN TERMS OF THE PRICING YOU CAN
SEE SANDWICH BOARDS LOCAL
STREETS WERE THERE. SHE
OFFERING HAIR CUTS AND- MORE
OFTEN THAN NOT THEY'RE CHARGING
MORE FOR A WOMAN'S HAIR CUT I
GO INTO THOSE ESTABLISHMENTS
AND TRY TO EXPLAIN TO THEM
THEIR VIOLATING THE LAW BUT-
DOESN'T SEEM TO BOTHER THEM
THEY ALSO DON'T WANT TO GIVE ME
A HAIR CUT. THAT'S PROBABLY
SMART THE UNITED WHEN FROM THEM
EITHER BUT OF COURSE WITH HER
CUTS THE DIFFERENTIAL IN
PRICING IT CAN BE LEGITIMATE IF
IT TAKES MORE TIME IF TAKES
FIVE MINUTES. THE LAW PROVIDES
IT SHOULD BE IF YOU'RE SHORT AS
YOURS IS- YOU KNOW IT DOES IT
TAKE MORE TIME TO CUT YOUR HAIR
THAN TO CUT. YOUR GENERAL
COUNSELS MAYBE. I HOPE SO. BUT
THE THAT'S THE POOL SINCE THE
POINT NO NO NO I THINK THAT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THAT WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE IS PRICING
THAT'S BASED ON GENDER. AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS LEGISLATION
TALKS ABOUT IF THERE'S A
LEGITIMATE JUSTIFICATION IF THE
COST OF A PRODUCT OF THAT IS
GOING INTO SOMETHING THAT WE
SELL IF THE COSTS THAT PRODUCT
IS MORE THAN YOU CAN CHARGE
MORE BUT IF YOU'RE GOING TO
CHARGE MORE CASSETTES PINK AND
THAT'S BLACK THAT IS NOT.
SUFFICIENT JUSTIFICATION AND IF
YOU LOOK AT THE SAY ARE EXACTLY
THE SAME SHIP DOWN TO THE HEELS
THE OR TO THE TO THE SOLES OF
THE SHOES OF THE SAME THING
WITH THAT SO MANY OF THESE
PRODUCTS- SO- SO THE ARGUMENT
THAT IS GOING TO OPEN A
FLOODGATE A LITIGATION IS JUST
NOT ACCURATE- YOU HAVE. IN
RECENT CON. WE'VE HEARD THAT TO
US SOME PEOPLE ARGUE THE MARKET
WILL SOLVE THIS ISSUE SO
THERE'S NO NEED FOR GOVERNMENT
INTERVENTION- DID YOU ALSO HEAR
THOSE ARGUMENTS BACK IN
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE WHEN YOU
WERE. A PUSHING THE LEGISLATION
TO ADDRESS THE PAIN TAX FOR
SERVICES. AND DO YOU THINK THAT
THE MARKET HAS IN FACT FIX THAT
PROBLEM IN THE LAST TWENTY FIVE
YEARS I THINK THE EVIDENCE-
SPEAKS FOR ITSELF NOT ONLY HAS
IT NOT- FIX THE PROBLEM OF THE
PROBLEM. IN MANY RESPECTS HAS
BEEN EXACERBATED. AND THAT'S
BECAUSE- BECAUSE- SELLERS CAN
GET AWAY THINK THEY CAN GET
AWAY WITH IT AND TAKE FULL
ADVANTAGE OF MAXIMIZING THEIR
PROFITS. SO YOUR BILL IS BEEN
INTRODUCED IN CONGRESS- YOU ARE
EXPECTING NEVER HEARING AT WHAT
POINT. WE THINK WITHIN THE NEXT
TWO OR THREE MONTHS. AND IS
THERE ANYTHING WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING FOR ANYTHING THAT YOU
CAN SUGGEST- BASED UPON YOUR
EXPERIENCE AS FAR AS- THIS
LEGISLATION WE'RE INTRODUCING
IN CALIFORNIA TO YOU-
ANTICIPATE TO SIMILAR
COMPLAINTS TO AS TO WHAT YOU
HEARD BACK IN. THE NINETEEN
NINETIES FOR YOUR LEGISLATION
AND HOW WOULD YOU RESPOND TO
THAT SO. THERE'S ALWAYS GOING
TO BE AN ARGUMENT MADE THE
QUESTION BECOMES IT IS THIS A
FORMER DISCRIMINATION. IF YOU
CAN MAKE THE CASE THAT YOU
POINTED OUT THAT IT TAKES MORE
TIME TO SELL THAT PAIRED
TOGETHER OR TO CUT THAT HERE
THAT IS A LEGITIMATE BASIS BUT
NOT. SIMPLY BECAUSE IT IS PINK
OR BLUE SO ON IT AS IT RELATES
TO MY LEGISLATION IT WOULD MAKE
THE FEDERAL TRADE COMMISSION-
THE ARBITER AND IT WOULD BE
DEEMED TO BE A VIOLATION- UNDER
THE LAW AS AN UNFAIR OR
DECEPTIVE PRACTICE. HE WOULD
ALSO GIVE THE STATE'S
ATTORNEY'S GENERALS THE
AUTHORITY TO BRING CIVIL ACTION
ON BEHALF OF ALL RESIDENTS OF
THEIR STATE- IN ORDER TO.
COMPEL COMPLIANCE BUT YOU ONE
OF THE THINGS YOU CERTAINLY
KNOW AS AS MEMBERS OF FROM THIS
AUGUST BODY IS THAT. A
CALIFORNIA OFTEN LEADS THE WAY.
AND THERE ARE PLENTY OF
EXAMPLES WHEN I WAS HERE WE
WOULD PASS LEGISLATION AND THEN
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WOULD
TAKE NOTICE BECAUSE THEY DON'T
WANT TO HAVE FIFTY DIFFERENT
STATE. RULES AND I THINK IF YOU
WOULD HAVE. KIND OF PAVE THE
WAY ONCE AGAIN THAT OULD BE
VERY HELPFUL TO US ON A FEDERAL
LEVEL. THANK YOU EXACTLY WHAT I
WAS HOPING YOU WOULD SAY-
SENATOR RUBIO THE- AND THEN
SENATOR UNDER US. FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING TO
SEE US HERE TODAY WERE HONORED
TO HAVE YOU- ESPECIALLY FOR THE
WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE ON THIS
ISSUE. AND I THINK THAT AS WE
TALK ABOUT DISCRIMINATION AS IT
PERTAINS TO PAYING AND BLUE OR
PINK AND BLACK FOR MALE VERSUS
FEMALE ME WE KNOW THAT ALSO WE
HAVE INVOLVED AS A SOCIETY AND
IT'S ALSO. DISCRIMINATORY
DISCRIMINATORY IN DIFFERENT
FRIENDS BECAUSE WE WERE ALSO
MAKING ASSUMPTION THAT. MEN
WOULD PREFER BLACK VERSUS
PAYING QUIRK OR VICE VERSA SO I
THINK THAT- AGAIN AS A SOCIETY
WE HAVE A BOB AS A PERTAINS TO
COLORS AND PREFERENCES AND NOW
PEOPLE CHOOSE DIFFERENT COLORS
FOR DIFFERENT TIMES AND- AND
DIFFERENT. IN OCCASION SO I
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND I WOULD
JUST ALSO BE CURIOUS TO. TO
KNOW. CERTAIN RESPECT BECAUSE
NOW WE KNOW WE HAVE THE LGBT
COMMUNITY WE HAVE TRANSGENDER
COMMUNITY NINE NON BY IN BINARY
AND SO NOW THERE'S SO MANY
THINGS THAT WE HAVE TO LOOK. TO
NOT JUST PAINT AND BLACK SO YOU
KNOW I WOULD BE CURIOUS TO SEE
YOU YOU KNOW ALSO RESEARCH ON
THAT FRONT IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW
DO. ALSO ARE THERE IN ALL
GENDERS FEEL DISCRIMINATED NOT
JUST FEMALES BUT TRANSIT AND-
INTO TO BE TO Q. CAN BE SELF.
THAT INFORMATION BECAUSE EVERY
TO US I WOULD LET TO SET UP A
THANK YOU SO MUCH I REALLY. IT
WILL COME THIS AND I THINK THAT
YOU YOU START. AT THIS AND YOU
PAVE THE WAY FOR NOW TAKE THEM
TO THE FOR THAT. SENATOR I'M AS
I COULD DO THE TWO. THE THIS
OFFICE OF RESEARCH PROVIDE US.
POLITY RESEARCH THAT HAS BEEN.
AROUND PROTECT NOW. POSSIBLE
SENATE OFFICE OF RESEARCH COULD.
TO THE KIND OF A RE SUGGESTS
AND MAYBE UPDATE THE RE SIX
COULD BE DONE ON PRODUCTS
BECAUSE THAT LAST REVIEW WAS ON
SERVICES. HOPE WE CAN DO THAT
HI ADD THAT SO YEARS A WINDY
DAVIS WAS ON THE FLOOR OF THE
LET. WE WERE IN SUCH. AND
CHOOSE WEARING KINKS. AND WE
WANTED A TO ON HER AS A AFTER
THAT IT NINE OR TEN OR LIVE IN
OUR CAN'T MAY FOR. THEY WANTED
TO GET RID OF THE REPORT.
HEALTH CARE LEGISLATION THAT
THAT EVERYONE HAD FOUGHT SO
HARD FOR- AND I CAN TELL YOU
THAT SOME OF OUR MALE
COLLEAGUES DID HAVE DIFFICULTY
FINDING PINK SNEAKERS IN MIL
SIZES. SO I DON'T KNOW IF THAT
YOU KNOW I KNOW THERE WERE A
FEW WHO REALLY WANTED TO I
DON'T KNOW OF SENATOR HILL WAS
ABLE TO DO THAT ARE YOU MORE
PINK TIE BUT A CLEARLY WE STILL
HAVE THAT- THAT BIAS AND THOSE
OBSTACLES TO ADDRESS- I HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO WEAR THE PINK ONES
FOR MUCH MYSELF- BUT I'D BE
INTERESTS SEE HOW MANY OF OUR
MALE COLLEAGUES WHO ACTUALLY
BOUGHT THOSE PINK SNEAKERS. ARE
PREPARED TO WEAR THEM ON THE
FLOOR TODAY SENATOR RUSSELL THE
FLOORS YES. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SENATOR CONGRESS WOMAN.
AND WHATEVER OTHER TITLES I YOU
HAVE- MY QUESTION IS IF YOU
HAVE ANY SENSE IN THE RESEARCH
FOR YOU AND EXPERIENCE AS TO
WHERE. AND HOW THE DECISION IS
MADE ABOUT. TRY MORE. BECAUSE
WE KNOW IN THE READ WORLD.
THERE'S DIFFERENT LEVELS AND
THE COMPANY THAT SELLS THESE
PRODUCTS SO. IS IT THE
MANUFACTURER IS IT. YOU KNOW AT
THE- STORE LEVEL THE RETAIL
LEVEL IS AT THE WHOLESALE LEVEL
TO HAVE ANY SENSE OF THAT
BECAUSE- IT SEEMS TO ME IT IN
THE- END THE LEGISLATION RIGHT
TO REALLY HOLD. THE DECISION
MAKER ACCOUNTABLE IT BE GOOD TO
MAKE SURE WE COVERED OURS
OURSELVES ON ALL THOSE LEVELS
BECAUSE- YOU KNOW WE HEAR ABOUT
THOSE DIFFERENT. LEVELS OF A
COMPANY OR MANY COMPANIES THAT
ARE INVOLVED IN I 'T
ONE TO SLIP AWAY IF THAT'S WITH
THE DECISIONS BEING MADE.
QUESTION SENATOR IN SOME CASES
I THINK IT'S THE MANUFACTURE
BUT IN SOME CASES IT'S A
DISTRIBUTOR IN SOME CASES IT'S
THE RETAILER. BUT THERE ARE
COMPANIES THAT HAVE- ONLINE
COMPANIES NOW THAT HAVE
RECOGNIZED THE- HELLO. HOW
WRONG THIS IS AND ONE OF THE
COMPANIES IS CALLED BOXED AND
THEY SELL PRODUCTS ONLINE AND
THEY MAKE A POINT OF. A
PROMOTING THEIR PRODUCTS. AS
NON DISCRIMINATORY SO IF YOU
BOUGHT TEDDY BEARS FROM THEM
THEY'RE GOING TO BE THE SAME
PRICE. AND WE WILL BE HEARING
FROM THE COMPANY. SO YES THAT
IS SO IT DOES. SOME SOME OF THE
DETERMINATIONS ARE MADE AT THE
MANUFACTURING LEVEL SOME OF THE
DISTRIBUTION LEVEL AND SOME OF
THE RETAIL LEVEL AND THE BILL
TRIES TO GET AT THAT THE
PARTICULAR DECISION MAKER. SO
IF A MANUFACTURER FOR EXAMPLE-
ITEMIZE HIS AND CHARGES MORE
FOR THE PRODUCT AND THEN THAT
IS ABSORBED GOING FORWARD IT'S
THE MANUFACTURER THAT WE WOULD
BE LOOKING TO IF IT COMES TO A
RETAIL STORE BIG BOX OR AMAZON
OR SOME ONLINE COMPANY. AND
THEY JUST DECIDE TO CHARGE MORE
THE BILL WOULD ADDRESS THEIR
BEHAVIOR. A SENATOR HILL THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR IS THE YOU TO
MY CONGRESS WHO IS A- ALWAYS
SUCH A OF. A LEADER WHEN IT
COMES TO. JUST ABOUT EVERYTHING
IN FACT WHEN I THINK OF IT BUT
TO BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
CONSUMER RIGHTS AND CONSUMER TO
CONSUMER PROTECTION AND
CERTAINLY THE- THE EQUALITY
THAT WE ALL WANT AND EXPECT
FROM- FROM A MARKET PLACE IN
WERE NOT SEEN THAT I REMEMBER
IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES WHEN
YOU HAVE THAT LEGISLATION AND
WE'RE PUSHING IT. IT WAS HARD
FOR ME TO BELIEVE AT THE TIME
THAT YOU COULD GO TO A DRY
CLEANERS AND YOU KNOW MY WIFE'S
BLOUSE WOULD BE MORE EXPENSIVE
THAN MY ALWAYS NEWS OR BUT I
ALWAYS FELT THERE HAD TO BE A
REASON FOR IT. BUT WHAT WOULD
IN IN FOLLOWING UP ON SENATOR
GRUDGES. QUESTION THIS IS SO
PERVASIVE FROM WHAT I'VE SEEN
AND THEN LOOK AT THE NEW YORK
STUDY THAT WE HAVE A COPY OF.
IT JUST TOUCHES EVERY AREA. OF
CONSUMER PRODUCTS AND WHICH
WOULD STRIKES ME IS. THERE HAS
TO BE SOME. SOME SOME IN
LOOKING FOR TO THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PANEL THERE HAS
TO BE REAL REAL FOR THIS TO ME
THE MARKET TO TECHNIQUE SECRET
THAT THEY KNOW THAT THEY CAN
GET AWAY WITH IT BY TO EDIT AND
ONE THAT IT IT WORKS IN THAT
PEOPLE WILL UNDERSTAND THAT AND
EXPECT THAT THERE WOULD BE
DIFFERENT SO I'M I'M TRYING TO
GET AT THE HEART IN THAT THE-
THE CORE OF THE ISSUE AND THEN
AND THEN HOPEFULLY WE CAN
CORRECT IT FROM THERE AND MOVE
FORWARD SO I I'M JUST. I'M
EXCITED TO MOVE FORWARD IN
SUPPORTING THE BILL IN THE
LEGISLATION YES SENATOR THERE'S
A LINE THAT IS USED IN MADISON
AVENUE THAT SAYS THAT SHRINK IT
AND PICK IT IN YOU CAN MAKE
MORE PROFIT. INTEREST FOR THE
NEXT THAT'S WHERE IT'S COMING
FROM THANK YOU I THINK THE
BOTTOM LINE IS STATE CHARGE
MORE BECAUSE THEY CAN. AND
HOPEFULLY WE GONNA. MAKE THEM
MAKE PEOPLE MORE AWARE YOU KNOW
THEY SHOULD. WITH THE SHORT
HIKE D. TO FOLLOW PLEDGES. AND
SO YEARS AGO WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY. BECAUSE I HAD TAKEN
MY HUSBAND'S SHIRT TO THE
CLEANER IN MARCH FOR TO THE
CLEANERS MY HUSBAND'S SIX FOUR.
HUNDRED EIGHTY POUNDS AND I'M
NOT. AND HE SURE COST A DOLLAR
AND A QUARTER TO LAUNDER AND
MINE COST FOUR DOLLARS AND
SEVENTY FIVE CENTS. AND SO I
ASKED THEM WHY IN THEIR
EXPLANATION WAS WELL HIS SHIRT
BUTTONS ON. THE BUTTONS ON A
MAN'S SHIRT BUTTON RIGHT TO
LEFT OR LEFT TO RIGHT I CAN
REMEMBER AND YOURS BUTTON IN
THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION. AND THE
PRESSES THAT WE USE- ARE
ACCOMMODATE A MAN'S SHIRT BUT
CAN'T ACCOMMODATE A WOMAN'S SO
WE HAVE TO HAND. IRON A WOMAN
SHIRT. AND I REMEMBER THEM
THINKING MY GOODNESS WE PUT A
MAN ON THE MOON WE CAN'T FIGURE
OUT HOW TO DO THIS. FAST FOR
TWENTY YEARS LATER IT'S STILL
THE SAME PROBLEM WHY. BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T. SO THAT'S ANOTHER.
BUT A THAT'S- AND WE KNOW YOU
GAVE AN EXAMPLE EARLIER OF THE
BOYFRIENDS- ASSURED WHY DON'T
YOU. CLOSE WITH THAT BECAUSE I
WANT TO MAKE SURE YOU DON'T
MISS YOUR PLANE- GONNA GET BACK
TO. DC THERE AND- IT AS AN
EXAMPLE IF YOU SHARE WITH US
THAT STORY ABOUT THE MAN'S
SHIRT. BOYFRIEND SHIRT. I
THOUGHT IT ACTUALLY A OUT. MR
HALL OF OUR HEART OKAY ALL
RIGHT BUT I GUESS IT WAS ONE OF
THE COMPANIES THAT WERE VERY
AWAY OF WHO WERE. OF ACTUALLY
MARKETING THE BOY FOR. SHIRT
WOMEN NOW THAT THEY HAD
DESIGNED ONE SO YOU CAN BE JUST
LIKE YOUR BOYFRIEND EXCEPT YOU
COULD HAVE YOUR YOUR MATCHING
HAVE MATCHED MATCHING SHIRTS
THAT THEY CHARGE MORE FOR THE
GIRLFRIEND SHERATON. BOY
FURNITURE. SO IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE IN AND WE'LL YOU US
MUCH FOR YEARS ON THIS IN YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND YOU KNOW IT'S
ALWAYS BEEN A HONORING A PLAY
FOR ME TO TRY TO FOLLOW IN YOUR
VERY LARGE FOOTSTEPS ON THESE
ISSUES AND I JUST THANK YOU FOR
ALL THE WORK YOU'VE DONE AND
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING SOME
SUCCESS HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
HOPEFULLY IN WASHINGTON DC ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR INTO TO ALL OF YOU.
I THINK I WOULD JUST CLOSE BY
SAYING WE REALLY ARE THE
GUARDIANS FOR THE PUBLIC MANY
OF MY LEADS PIECES OF
LEGISLATION ON CONSUMER
PROTECTION HAD TO DO WITH THE
FACT THAT I FELT THAT WE WERE
THEIR GUARDIAN AND IT WAS OUR
OBLIGATION TO GO WHERE THEY MAY
NOT SEE A NEED- OR NOT MAY NOT
BE EDUCATED ABOUT. A PARTICULAR
ISSUE AND- MAKE SURE THAT WE
WERE THERE TO PROTECT THEM SO-
I KNOW YOU WILL DO THE RIGHT
THING AND I THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY THANK
YOU SO MUCH COMMERCE MEMBER
SAFE TRAVELS AND KEEP UP THE
GREAT WORK WE- THINK WE ALL
ADMIRED. YOUR POSITIONS. SO
WITH I'M TO GO BACK AND ADJUST
TO IT ALSO WOULD MAKE IT COM
THAT WILL WERE PRO I THINK IS
AN INTRODUCTION BUT BEING
COGNIZANT OF THE CONGRESSWOMAN
SAYS SCHEDULE THAT LET ME JUST
SAY I WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT
WERE WE'RE DOING HERE IS. WE
WANT OUR BILL. IN AND TO
THRIVE. AS THEY ARE NOW SO THE
GOAL HERE IS TO ALLOW IN TO
ENCOURAGE BUSINESSES TO DO SO
TO MAKE PROFITS CREATE JOBS.
BUT WHAT WE DON'T WANT IS. WHAT
I BELIEVE NONE OF US SHOULD
TOLERATE IS PRICING
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST WOMEN
AND GIRLS. THEY SHOULD NOT BE
DISCRIMINATION AND PRICING AND
I ALSO WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT
WHILE- I BELIEVE THE PINK TAX
IS WRONG. AS I MENTIONED. A I
AND I THINK EVERYONE ON THIS
DíAS IS LOOKING FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY. THE BEST WAY TO
ELIMINATE THAT- THAT WILL BE
EFFECTIVE SO NOT A WHIT WINDOW
DRESSING APPROACH BUT SOMETHING
THAT REALLY IS GOING TO BE FAIR
TO THE WOMEN AND THE FAMILIES.
IN OUR STATE AND HOPEFULLY THAT
THE NATION WILL THEN FOLLOW SO.
THE GOAL IS TO THINK A- IN
BROAD TODAY AND- THIS IS NOT.
JUST THE KIND OF A ROAD HEARING
I THINK WE'RE LOOKING FOR SOME
REAL ANSWERS SOME REAL
DISCUSSION. I AM HOPEFUL THAT
WE CAN WORK WITH SOME OF THE
FOLKS WHO HAVE INDICATED. THEIR
INITIAL STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL THAT THE- WILL COME TO
THE TABLE AND WORK WITH US TO
COME UP WITH A SOLUTION THAT
ADDRESSES THAT PROBLEM WHILE AT
THE SAME TIME. ENCOURAGING
BUSINESS TO CONTINUE TO
FLOURISH SO. I WANT TO MAKE
SURE TO THAT WE WERE GOING TO
HAVE TWO PANELS AT THE END WILL
INVITE ANY MEMBER THE PUBLIC OR
ANYONE WHO IS NOT OTHERWISE
BEEN GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO COME FORWARD TO THE
MICROPHONE. OF FOR IT TO UP TO
TWO MINUTES TO SHARE THEIR
PERSPECTIVES. AND THEN IT IS MY
HOPE THAT WE WILL COME TOGETHER
AS A LEGISLATIVE BODY AND WORK
OUT A SOLUTION TO THIS TO THIS
ISSUE SO WITHOUT FURTHER ADO-
LET ME- ASK OUR FIRST A PANEL.
TO COME FORWARD- THEY'LL
ADDRESS THE ECONOMIC AND
CULTURAL IMPACTS OF THE PINK
TAX ON WOMEN'S LIVES WE HAVE.
DOCTOR ELIZABETH SUITE. HE
WOULD COME FORWARD- SHE'S AN
ASSISTANT PROFESSOR IN
SOCIOLOGY IN INTERDISCIPLINARY
SOCIAL SCIENCES AT SAN JOSE
STATE. OF HER FOCUS IN
RESEARCHES ON GENDER AND
CHILDREN'S TOYS SO SOME OF
THESE ARE PROBABLY FAMILIAR TO
YOU. SHE EARNED HER PHD IN
SOCIOLOGY AT UC DAVIS IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN. AND IS INTERESTED
BROADLY IN THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN CULTURAL BELIEFS AND
SOCIAL INEQUALITIES. OF HER
CURRENT RESEARCH EXAMINES THE
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN GENDER.
CHILDREN'S TOYS AND GENDER
INEQUALITY OVER THE TWENTIETH
CENTURY IN A SOMEONE WHO HATED
DOLLS AS A LITTLE GIRL AND
WANTED TO PLAY BASEBALL. I'LL
BE VERY INTERESTED IN WHAT YOU
HAVE TO SAY WE ALSO HAVE WITH
US SERENA CON. WHO IS THE CITY
CHIEF A. OFFICER OF THE WOMEN'S
FOR. UNDER OF CAL. THE READ. X.
ON. RACE ANY JUST AND A FREE
COM. ON THE- OF WOMEN'S FULLER.
HER WRITING RESEARCH OF THE
PUBLISHED WIDELY IMPRINT AND
ONLINE. INCLUDING THE SACK BE
THE SAN FRANCISCO CHRONICLE SAN
JOSE MERCURY NEWSTHE STANFORD
SOCIAL INNOVATION REVIEW. AND
THE PHILANTHROPY NEWS DIGEST
THANK YOU BOTH FOR TAKING THE
TIME TO SHARE YOUR EXPERTISE
WITH US TODAY AND LET'S START.
WITH DR SUITE. MEMBERS IT'S
TRULY HONOR TO BE HERE YOU
TODAY. USING MY IS DOCTOR SWEET
AND I'M IN A SYSTEM OF
SOCIOLOGY AT SAN THESE. MY
EXPERTISE A JACKSON'S LIES IN
THE AREA GENDER AND CALLED AND
MY CURRENT RESEARCH FOCUSES ON
JENNER MARKETING IN STEREO
TYPING OF CHILDREN'S TOYS OVER
TIME. SO IN ADDITION TO THE
ECONOMIC CONSEQUENCES OF THE
PINK TAX THAT MS KAHN WILL BE
SPEAKING AT. I'M JENNER
PRODUCTS AND PRICING ALSO HAVE
CULTURAL CONSEQUENCES FOR MY
REMARKS WILL FOCUS ON THE
CULTURAL SIGNIFICANCE OF DENT
GENDER DIFFERENTIATED PRODUCTS
AND PRICING. WHY OF THE THINGS
I FIND IN MY RESEARCH IS THAT
WHILE THE GENDER MARKETING OF
TOYS HAS VARIED OVER TIME THIS
PRACTICE HAS INCREASED
DRAMATICALLY OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL DECADES. IN MY ANALYSIS
OF OVER SEVEN THOUSAND SEARS
CATALOGUE TôI ADVERTISEMENTS
THAT SPAN THE TWENTIETH CENTURY
I FOUND THAT THE MAJORITY OF
TOYS WERE MARKETED IN A NON
GENDERED OR GENDER INCLUSIVE
WAY. EVEN IN THE DECADES ONE
GENDER MARKETING WAS THE MOST
PRONOUNCED GENDER TOYS STILL
ONLY MADE UP AROUND HALF OF THE
TOYS ADVERTISE IT. IN CONTRAST
A TWENTY TWELVE STUDY BY
SOCIOLOGISTS OSTERN MONTHS BACH
FOUND THAT ALL OF THE TOYS IN
THE DISNEY ONLINE STORE WERE
CATEGORIZED BY ENDER. AND
GENDER DIFFERENT
DIFFERENTIATION ISN'T JUST A
FEATURE OF CHILDREN'S TOYS I
TWENTY NINETEEN STUDY BY
STANFORD RESEARCHERS FOUND
EVIDENCE OF EXTENSIVE GENDER
TYPING AN ADULT PRODUCT MARKETS
AS WELL. ADDITIONALLY I FIND IN
MY RESEARCH THAT THE PRACTICE
OF CREATING SEPARATE GENDER
CODED VERSIONS OF THE SAME TôI
ONLY EMERGES AT THE TAIL END OF
THE TWENTIETH CENTURY. THE
HISTORICAL VARIATION IN THE
CHEN OR MARKETING OF TOYS AND
OTHER PRODUCTS TELLS US THAT
THESE ITEMS ARE NOT INHERENTLY
GENDERED. RATHER THE GENDER
CODING OF PRODUCTS REFLECTS OUR
CULTURAL BELIEFS AND PRACTICES
IT ALSO TELLS US THAT
ALTERNATIVE WAYS OF PRODUCING
MARKETING AND PRICING PRODUCTS
IS POSSIBLE. THIS BEGS THE
QUESTION THEN WHY DO COMPANIES
DESIGN MARKET AND SOMETIMES
PRICE PRODUCTS DIFFERENTLY
ACCORDING TO GENDER. THE GROWTH
OF MARKET SEGMENTATION AND
TARGETING MARKETING PRACTICES
IN PARTICULARLY IN THE LAST
DECADES OF THE TWENTIETH
CENTURY A BIG PART OF THIS
STORY. COMPANIES ARE ALWAYS
LOOKING TO INCREASE SALES SO
WHY SOMEONE FAMILY ONE BOTTLE
OF SHAMPOO WHEN YOU COULD SELL
EACH MEMBER OF THAT FAMILY
THEIR OWN BOTTLE. COMPANIES USE
GENDER TO SEGMENT THE MARKET
BECAUSE IT'S AN EASILY
IDENTIFIABLE CHARACTERISTIC
AROUND WHICH MUCH OF SOCIAL
LIFE IS ORGANIZED. GENDER
STEREOTYPES LEE AT THE CORE OF
MARKET SEGMENTATION AND
TARGETING STRATEGIES. PRODUCT
MAKERS OF MARKETERS OFTEN RELY
HEAVILY ON STEREOTYPES IN THEIR
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT WHAT MALES
AND FEMALES ARE LIKE WHAT THEY
SHOULD BE LIKE AND WHAT THEY
WANT. MARKETING PROFESSOR SUSAN
MARKETING TO DESCRIBE HOW
COMPANIES USE CHARACTERISTICS
LIKE GENDER TO MARKET AND IN
THE PROCESS ACTUALLY CREATE THE
VERY DIFFERENCES THEY CLAIM TO
ADDRESS. THE BIG FOR HER PENS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE HEARD ABOUT
OUR GREAT EXAMPLE OF THIS HAS A
SUGGESTED THAT WOMEN SOMEHOW
HAD FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT
RATING NEEDS THAN MEN EVEN
THOUGH MEN AND WOMEN HAVE BEEN
USING THE SAME TENS. OF
OVERTIME. I TWO THOUSAND STUDY
WHICH- GENDER PRICE DIFFERENCE
AND- FOUND THAT THE- WHICH-
MOST TO THE CONSTRUCTION OF
WHAT THE AUTHORS CALL THE
GENDER ITSELF THINGS LIKE HAIR
STYLES AND PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS. ARE ALSO THE MOST
LIKELY TO BE PRICE DIFFERENTLY
BY GENDER. SOME PRODUCTS ARE
NOT INHERENTLY GENDERED AS I AM
ARGUING THAT HOW DID THEY
BECOME ENGENDERED. COMPANIES
TYPICALLY HAVE A TARGET
DEMOGRAPHIC IN MIND WHEN THEY
CREATE A PRODUCT EVEN IF THE
PRODUCT ITSELF IS OSTENSIBLY
GENDER NEUTRAL. THERE ARE
SEVERAL STRATEGIES THAT THEY
THEN USED TO GENDER DIFFERENT
CHEAP PRODUCTS SOMETIMES
PRODUCTS ARE CHEN EXPLICITLY
GENDER LABEL FOR EXAMPLE MEN'S
RAZORS ARE GIRLS SCOOTERS. IN
OTHER CASES COMPANIES RELY MORE
IMPLICIT THOUGH OFTEN NO LESS
OBVIOUS CUES. THESE MAY INCLUDE
THE PLACEMENT OF PRODUCTS IN
STORES AND ONLINE PAGES THE USE
OF A GENDERED MODEL IN PRODUCT
PACKAGING OR MARKETING AND THE
USE OF LANGUAGE THAT EVOKES
GENDER TEREOTYPES IN THE
PRODUCT PACKAGING OR MARKETING
WORDS LIKE TOUGH A DELICATE.
COLOR AS- THE CO PAYING AS
WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING. HAS COME
TO SERVE AS A PRETTY STRONG
GENDER USE TO DEFINE GEN.
CONSUMER HOWEVER COUNTRY TO POP
BELIEF THIS IS A RELATIVELY.
THAT IN HER RE ON HISTORICAL.
DOCTOR JOE PALE FOUND THAT THE
PINK FOR BLUE SORRY PAYING FOR
AND FOR BOY COLORS. ONLY EMERGE
IN THE FOR. AND ONLY GAINED
POPULARITY IN THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES SIMILARLY I FIND NO
EVIDENCE OF WHAT PEOPLE HAVE TO
DEBT THE PINK OF VACATION OF
GIRLS TOYS IN MY RESEARCH AND
EMERGING INTO THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES. WHILE THE USE OF
COLOR AND ESPECIALLY BECAUSE A
GENDER AS HISTORIC REESE AND-
RECENT STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT
THE USE OF COLOR INFLUENCES
BOTH HOW PEOPLE CLASSIFIED THE
GENDER OF A PRODUCT. WHETHER
THAT THEY FEEL THAT OUR PRODUCT
IS APPROPRIATE FOR THEM. THE
GENDER CATEGORIZATION OF
MARKETING A PRODUCT IS
PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE THE GENDER
STEREOTYPES THAT FORM THE BASIS
OF THIS PRACTICE ARE ALSO
DEEPLY IMPLICATED. IN THE
PROCESS HE'S AT SUSTAIN GENDER
INEQUALITY IN OUR SOCIETY.
THERE'S A WEALTH OF RESEARCH IN
SOCIOLOGY AND PSYCHOLOGY
LINKING GENDER STEREOTYPES TO
PERSISTENT SOCIETAL INEQUALITY
IS LIKE THE GENDER SO I
CREATION OF OCCUPATIONS AND THE
GENDER WAGE GAP. THIS RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT GENDER STEREOTYPES
CAN HAVE POWERFUL EFFECTS ON
BEHAVIORAL EXPECTATIONS ON TASK
PERFORMANCE AND HOW WE EVALUATE
OURSELVES AND OTHERS. AND
IMPORTANTLY ONE DOES NOT HAVE
TO BELIEVE THE STEREOTACTIC FOR
IT TO HAVE THAT PROFOUND EFFECT
ALL THAT'S NECESSARY IS TO KNOW
THAT IT'S OUT THERE AND THE
OTHERS BELIEVE IT TO BE TRUE.
GIVEN THE DATA FROM EFFECTS OF
GENDER STEREOTYPES IT IS
PARTICULARLY CONCERNING THAT
THEY BECOME SO DEEPLY WOVEN
INTO THEIR DESIGN MARKETING AND
PRICING OF CONTEMPORARY
CONSUMER PRODUCTS. WHAT THE
GENDER MARKETING IN DIFFERENT-
PRICING OF CONSUMER PRODUCTS
HAS BECOME A SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEM IN THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY IT IS ONE THAT IS
NEITHER INEVITABLE NOR
INTRACTABLE. IN FACT THERE ARE
SOME SIGNS THAT COMPANIES MAY
BE SHIFTING BACK TOWARDS MORE
GENDER NEUTRAL PRODUCT DESIGN
AND MARKETING AS A RECENT WALL
STREET JOURNAL ARTICLE ENTITLED
DOES YOUR REYES ARE NEEDED
GENDER EXPLAINS COMPANIES ARE
COMING TO REALIZE GENDER
DIFFERENTIATED PRODUCTS ARE
INCREASINGLY AT ODDS WITH WHERE
CONSUMERS ARE. AND SO I THINK
I'LL LEAVE IT. THERE YOU SO
MUCH I LOOK FOR YOUR CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL.
SERENA CONTAS AND THEN WE'LL
OPEN AND FOR. THANK YOU. AIR
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS SIR. COME I. THE CEO OF
THE WOMEN'S. OF CAL. WHICH IS A-
SO. FOR THAT IS IN OUR FORTY
FIRST YEAR THIS YEAR WE WERE
FOUNDED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE- AND WE INVEST IN AND
TRAIN AND CONNECT COMMUNITY
BASED LEADERS TO ADVANCE
GENDER. RACIAL AND ECONOMIC
JUSTICE- AS MANY OF YOU KNOW WE
HAVE A WOMEN'S POLICY INSTITUTE
WHERE WE- TRAIN COMMUNITY
BASED. LEADERS TO BE EFFECTIVE
PUBLIC POLICY ADVOCATES MANY OF
YOU HAVE. AUTHORED SOME OF
THEIR BILLS THEY- THAT NETWORK
OF NOW ALMOST SIX HUNDRED. A
COMMUNITY LEADERS IS CONNECTED
TO MILLIONS OF PEOPLE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THROUGH THEIR OWN
NETWORKS. AND SO WE- WANT TO
SUPPORT- AND REPRESENT THEIR
INTERESTS WHICH IS WHY WE ARE
HONORED TO BE A CO SPONSORING.
SB EIGHT SEVENTY THREE- AND AS
WE'VE HEARD EARLIER THAT
DESPITE EXISTING LEGISLATION
IT'S STILL FAR TOO EASY. FOR
PRODUCTS MARKETED TOWARDS WOMEN
TO COST MORE. AND CHARGING
WOMEN FOR ESSENTIALLY THE SAME
PRODUCTS IS GENDER
DISCRIMINATION- WHICH IS WHY WE
AT THE WOMEN'S FOUNDATION OF
CALIFORNIA- THINK THAT WE NEED
SENATE BILL EIGHT SEVENTY THREE
THE PINK TAX. REPEAL ACT. THE
PINK TAX REPEAL ACT TO RECTIFY
IS AN INJUSTICE IN OUR MARKET
PLACE THAT HAS. DRAMATIC
IMPLICATIONS FOR THE DAY TO DAY
LIVES AND FINANCIAL FUTURES OF
WOMEN AND OUR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES. ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
IN MY ROLE AS THE CEO OF THE
WOMEN'S FOUNDATION OF
CALIFORNIA. THE IMPORTANCE OF
LEGISLATION- LIKE SB EIGHT
SEVENTY THREE. THAT WRITES THE
SCALES OF ECONOMIC AND JUSTICE-
COULD NOT BE MORE CLEAR OR
NEEDED- N THISPARTICULAR
MOMENT. WE LIVE IN A WORLD
WHERE WOMEN MAKE BETWEEN 7280%
OF ALL CONSUMER PURCHASES. THAT
MEANS THAT WOMEN ARE CALLING
THE SHOTS ABOUT WHAT MAKES IT
INTO THE SHOPPING CART BUT
COMES HOME WITH US AND WHAT
DOESN'T. SO WITH THIS KNOWLEDGE
MARKETERS HAVE BEEN
MANIPULATING THE PRICE OF CAN.
GOODS FOR PROFIT ON BACKS OF
WOMEN IN OUR EARNED MONEY.
MARKETERS A BUNCH WITH A PINK
TAX ADDITIONAL COSTS. FOR BEING
WOMEN WHICH MEANS THAT HALF OF
THE POPULATION IS BEING
SUBJECTED TO AN ADDITIONAL TAX-
AND SO IF WE THINK ABOUT LET'S
SAY A MOM AND FRESNO WHO WANTS
TO BUY A BICYCLE FOR HER ELEVEN
YEAR OLD DAUGHTER TO RIDE
AROUND THE NEIGHBORHOOD RIGHT
NOW IT WOULD BE PERFECTLY LEGAL
FOR THAT BICYCLE TO COST AS
MUCH AS 13% MORE BECAUSE IT'S
PINK AND MARKETED TOWARDS
GIRLS. THIS KIND OF GENDER
BASED MANIPULATION OF THE
MARKET IS UNWARRANTED AND WHEN
YOU FACTOR IN THE REALITIES OF
OUR STATES GENDER PAY GAP IT
BECOMES ALL THE MORE CRITICAL-
THAT WE PASS AND IMPLEMENT SB
EIGHT SEVENTY THREE. SO TO PUT
THIS ANOTHER WAY WHICH IS THAT
WOMEN EARN LESS AND PAY MORE
THE PAINFUL TRUTH IS THAT
LATINO WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA EARN
ABOUT FORTY ONE CENTS FOR EVERY
DOLLAR THAT A MAN IS PAID. A
BLACK WOMAN MIGHT BE TAKING
HOME SIXTY CENTS ON A WHITE OR
ASIAN WOMAN WOULD TOP OUT AT
ABOUT EIGHTY CENTS- AND SO THIS
MEANS THAT WORKING WOMEN IN
CALIFORNIA LOSE OUT ON EIGHTY
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
BECAUSE OF THE GENDER PAY GAP
THAT'S EIGHTY SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS AND TRANSGENDER WOMEN.
ARE FOUR TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
LIVE IN POVERTY SINGLE MOTHERS
IN CALIFORNIA ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S WELL BEING
INDEX WHICH REPRODUCED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET AND POLICY
CENTER- SPEND NOT JUST ON TWO
LINE ITEMS IN THEIR BUDGET- ON
CHILD CARE AND HOUSING MORE
THAN A 100% OF WHAT THEY'RE
BRINGING HOME IN EVERYONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES. SO WHEN YOU
EXACERBATE THAT WITH THIS KIND
OFGENDER BASED DISCRIMINATION
IT'S REALLY COSTING OUR
FAMILIES A LOT SO WHEN RECHARGE
WOMEN GIRLS MORE FOR VERY SAME
PRODUCTS WE'RE REALLY YOU KNOW
CONTINUING THE DEEPER.
INEQUALITY THAT EXIST ACROSS
GENDER AND RACE LINES SO TO PUT
A FINER POINT ON IT IN ORDER TO
CLOSE THE ECONOMIC JASIM OPENED
UP BY THE GENDER. PAY GAP OF
LATINO WOMAN IN ROSEVILLE WHERE
HAVE JUST. AN ADDITIONAL. FOUR
ON THE UPTURN THIS AMOUNT OF
MONEY HER WAY MALE. SHE'D HAVE
TO WORK NEARLY AND HALF DAY.
LONGER TO EARN THE SAME AMOUNT
OF MONEY. SO WHEN WOMEN ARE
CHARGE MORE FOR SOAP OR A
TEACHER. IT ISN'T JUST AND FAIR
IT FURTHER COMPOUNDS THE
INJUSTICES THAT. THREATEN THEIR
FINANCIAL WELL BEING AND THE
ECONOMIC SECURITY OF THEIR
CHILDREN AND THEIR FAMILIES AND
I WOULD ARGUE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WITH THE PINK TAX
REPEAL ACT WE HAVE A CHANCE TO
CORRECT THIS. WITH THE PASSAGE
OF SB EIGHT SEVENTY THREE WE
CAN BRING GREATER FAIRNESS TO
OUR MARKETS AND WE CAN IMPROVE
THE FINANCIAL HEALTH AD WELL
BEING OF WOMEN AND GIRLS.
ACROSS OUR STATE AS WELL AS OUR
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES AND
ADDRESS SOME OF THE- VERY REAL
ISSUES OF POVERTY. HOMELESSNESS
HOUSING ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
THAT ARE RELATED. TO GENDER
BASED DISCRIMINATION OF
CONSUMER GOODS. I WANT TO
REINFORCE THE REAL SCALE OF
IMPACT THAT THE PAYING TAX
REPEAL ACT WOULD HAVE. ON THE
ECONOMIC WELL BEING OF
CALIFORNIA'S FAMILIES. MORE
THAN EVER BEFORE WOMEN ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROVIDING FOR
THEIR FAMILIES FINANCIALLY. THE
PRIMARY BREADWINNER AND NEARLY
HALF OF AMERICAN HOUSEHOLDS
WITH CHILDREN AS A WOMAN. SO
WHEN WE ADVANCE LEGISLATION
LIKE SB EIGHT SEVENTY THREE
WE'RE NOT JUST RECTIFYING
MANIPULATIONS OF THE MARKET
THAT UNFAIRLY TARGET WOMEN
WE'RE TAKING THE NECESSARY
STEPS TO MAKE SURE THAT
CHILDREN ACROSS OUR STATE. ARE
GROWING IN HOMES WITH A GREATER
DEGREE OF FINANCIAL SECURITY
ANDWELL BEING AND WE LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS. THAT GENDER
DISCRIMINATION OF THE PAYING
TAX IS EVER PRESENT ACROSS THE
WOMAN'S LIFETIME WHAT WHEN
SHE'S BORN THE PINK ONESIE IS
GOING TO COST. 4% MORE WHEN SHE
PLAYS MAKE BELIEVE HER TOYS
WILL COST 7% MORE. AS IN IT
SHE'S GOING TO BE CHARGED A
PERCENT MORE FOR THE CLOTHES
SHE PUTS ON. WHAT IN THE
MORNING. UP 240% MORE WHEN SHE
WASHES HER HAIR. AS SHE AGES
THE CANE SHE USES TO GET AROUND
IN THE ADULT DIAPERS THAT GIVE
HER THAT EXTRA PEACE OF MIND
WILL COST 8% MORE. OR MORE THE
PINK TAX IMPACTS WOMAN FROM
CRADLE TO GRAVE AND I REALLY
BELIEVE THAT IT MUST BE
REPEALED. THE PENTAX FOR ANY
ONE PURCHASE MAYBE RELATIVELY
SMALL BUT OVER THE COURSE OF A
LIFETIME IT REALLY ADDS UP.
WHETHER YOU TAKE A PRIME THE
WOMAN RIMARY YEARS ARE MEASURE
BASED ON. EXPECTED THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THAT PEOPLE CAN. SIR
THANK ENDS OF THE OF DOLLARS.
PER WHICH IS A HIGH AND EIGHTY
EIGHT THAT DOLLARS AND- THAN
THEIR MALE. FOR WATER. EGGS THE
SAME THING. SO WHY WOMEN GOTTEN
SO PAYING PAINTER WERE ALSO THE
ONES LEADING THE CHARGE TO AND
IT'S WE THANK SENATOR. FOR HER.
TO A- THIS BILL IS WELL AS SO
MANY GENDER JUSTICE. A I THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR TIME ATTENTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT HI WOULD
LIKE TO ADD DARK SUITE. UP
PROHIBITING PAYING TAX WOULDN'T
PREVENT BUSINESSES FROM BASED
ON GENDER WOULD NOT ACTUALLY- A
JUST COULDN'T PRY COULDN'T
PRICE BASED ON GENDER OR AT OUR
AND DO YOU THINK THE BUSINESSES
WOULD MARKET LESS BASED ON
GENDER IF THERE WERE NO
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE TO DO SO.
ARE THEY MIGHT YEAH I OR THEY
MIGHT YET BECAUSE THEY MAKE THE
SAME PRODUCT BRAIDED BUT THEY
WOULDN'T NECESSARILY GENDER
CODED IN THE SAME WAY. AND HOW
DOES THE CHEN ATION OF PRODUCTS
AFFECT INDIVIDUALS. WHO DO NOT
IDENTIFY IS EITHER BOY OR GIRL
MAN OR WOMAN AS WAS SUGGESTED
EARLIER BY SENATOR RUBIO I
GUESS WE CALL IT NOW. GENDER
FLUIDITY AND WE SEE IT MORE AND
MORE IN OUR YOUNG KIDS TODAY
AND TO- HOW HOW DO OF. HOW DOES
THIS SAID GENDERS ATION AFFECT
THE OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS WELL I
THINK THE REALITY OF THE GENDER
CUTTING OF PRODUCTS IS THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
DON'T NECESSARILY A LOT OF
WOMEN WHO DON'T NECESSARILY
LIKE PINK BUT IF THAT'S ALL YOU
CAN FIND OUT SO YOU CAN FIND.
TIAS POWER MAN LET WOMEN LIKE
HER VERY SORT OF NEW. BRIDGET
AND IT. LOT MORE VERY. MEN AND
AMONG WOMEN THERE ARE GROUP
LEVEL THAT BE THEM AND SIR
THAT'S TRUE WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
YOU KNOW HOW PEOPLE LIVE XP.
FENDER IDENTITY GENDER
EXPRESSION.FOR OKAY FLOW AND
ON THE SPECTRUM THAN THE RIGID
BINARY CARE. CHORUS. THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTION IN THE DRAW. HOW
MUCH A CO WELLS IS. THE NATURE
OF TOLL OR THE PRICE I IS IT'S
NOT THE TACK OR THE FIND. ISSUE
AS MUCH AS IT IS HOW WERE REYES
OUR SONS AND TO THINK THAT.
THIS CALL. ME BY DOING THIS THE
DECADE DE. THEN YOU PRETTY MUCH
THE THEM THE THERE'S A CERTAIN
CA FOR GIRLS AND WOMEN AND THEN
THERE'S THIS COLOR NOT REALLY.
IT'S A THE AWAY AWAY FOR HAVING
EQUALITY SO I JUST WHAT I YOU
KNOW I WAS A THIS SIGNS WITH
WITH MY TO GRAN. THEY SAID YOU
KNOW THEY WERE STILL YOUNG IN
THEY WANTED IN ORDER SINCE I
WAS LOOKING LOOK SO EXCITED
BECAUSE I. A NASSAU KIND OF
YOUR LIKE THE SPY CHI OF OUTFIT
AND I WAS RELEASED THAT WE GET
HOME THE OPEN IT THIS IS
WEARING HIGH HEEL. AND OF THE-
WOULD A NASA YOU SIGNED TO BE
WARY. I MEAN YOU COULD BUT IT
HAVE TO ANOTHER A WRIST PER.
THAT IF YOU'RE DAHLE YOU HAVE
TO BE THESE STILLER. MAYBE I'M
JEALOUS BECAUSE CAN'T WORK MANY
MORE. THE MAYBE THAT'S WHAT WAS
THE CITY OF THE BUT A KIND OF
GOES THINK OF. COLOR BUT TO THE
NAY. OF THE- AND I KNOW WE'RE
NOT GOING THAT THAT WITH THIS
LATEST OR TWO DAYS. BUT IT'S IN
THE DAY LOWTHAT REALLY BOTHERS.
AND DEVELOPING PSYCH HAVE DOING
A LOT OF RE ON THIS AND HAD
NICK. RESEARCH TAKE YOU KNOW I
TôI THAT. GENDER NEW. AND A
PAIN DIFFERENT COLORS THOUGH IF
THEY FIVE OUT THAT SHE HOW FEEL
ABOUT THE TôI WHETHER THEY
THINK OKAY THE END UP WITH AND
HOW AYE. THATTôI BY GENDER.
IT'S NOT THAT YOU KNOW HOW PINK
TRACK IS A PING DAHLE AND A TRY
ARE IN A- GENDER ITEMS THERE
JUST ITEM. THAT HAVE BEEN PAID
AND TO COLOR. YES SIR YOU
MENTION KEY ARE THAT THAT WE
THE WE A LOT OF THE IS DONE A
LOT OF MY- I MEAN THERE. THIRD
CORP. HUGE THAT ARE MARK BASED
AND A LOT OF THESE. CUES A VERY
A LOT OF THEM A BAY ON YOU KNOW
IF. STUDIES AND SO FORTH SO
THAT IS. THIS THAT IS OF THIS
WHOLE THIS. I CANNOT IMAGINE A
WOMAN GOING ON TO MAKE. ON THE
NASA TRIPLE MAKING I BUT THE IN
IN FISH. I WILL TO ASK SERENA.
SOME HAVE ARGUED CAN. SPENDING
IS IN WE CAN. SO IF A WOMAN SHE-
TO SPEND MORE THAN THAT'S ON.
TO HAVE A- THAT THANK. YEAH I
THINK YOU KNOW WE'VE- HERE
WHICH IS THAT WOMEN ARE IN
CHARGE OF MUCH OF WHAT GOES IN
OUR SHOPPING CART AND WHAT WE
BRING HOME AND- WE AND AS
THINGS ARE BEING MARKETED TO
WOMEN AND GIRLS SPECIFICALLY
BECAUSE SOME. OF SOME OF THE
CULTURAL- YOU KNOW. RIGID
GENDER NORMS THAT ARE BEING
REINFORCED BY THE MARKET. IT'S
GONNA BE HARD FOR SOME WOMEN
WHEN THEY HAVE- CHILDREN WHO
WANT THE PINK ITEM VERSUS THE
BLUE ITEM- TO GET THROUGH THE
GROCERY STORE SO WOMEN ARE
MAKING THESE CHOICES AND- THEY
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO- SO I THINK
IT'S INCUMBENT UPON US. TO
LEGISLATE EQUITY AND EQUALITY-
AND ADDRESS DISCRIMINATION
WHERE IT EXISTS WHICH IS IN
THIS- IN THE IN THE PRICING OF
PRODUCTS. THE READ IN A COMMENT.
ME WHAT WE USED TO SAY YEARS
AGO ABOUT. BATTERED WOMEN WELL
THEY CAN ALWAYS LEAVE. AND OF
COURSE THERE THERE ARE SO MANY
LAYERS TO THAT THEY CAN'T LEAVE
AND I SUSPECT WHEN IT COMES
THESE PRODUCTS. THERE HAVE ALSO
BEEN LEVELS OF- BOTH OVER TWO
AND A SUBTLE DISCRIMINATION
THAT ENTER INTO THIS THIS WHOLE
PROCESS. LAST QUESTION OF FOR
HOMES CON- DOES THE PINK TAX
AFFECT ALL WOMEN EQUALLY OR
DOES THE BURDEN FALLS
ESPECIALLY HEAVILY ON WOMEN OF
COLOR AND POOR WOMEN AND WOMEN
WHO ARE THE HEADS OF HOUSEHOLD.
YEAH I THINK IT FALLS MORE
HEAVILY ON LOW INCOME WOMEN- I
THINK IT FALLS MORE HEAVILY ON
TRANSGENDER WOMEN- WHO ARE MOST
MARGINALIZED WHEN IT COMES TO
ECONOMIC SECURITIES SO. THE
LAST WOMEN ARE PAYING AND THEN
HAVING TO PAY MORE FOR PRODUCTS
THEY'RE THEY'RE GOING TO BE
AFFECTED. OR SO AND- SENATOR TO
YOUR POINT I THINK THAT IT IS A-
INCUMBENT US TO ADDRESS
SYSTEMIC BARRIERS AND NOT LEAVE
IT TO THE INDIVIDUAL TO SOLVE
PROBLEMS- AT. THAT ARE CREATED
BY. OUR CALLED AND OUR MARKETS
SO WOULD YOU ARE BRIDGES ON
SOME OF THESE BARRIERS EXAMPLE
AM KNOW WE HERE OFFICE. AND ARE
US BECAUSE- WE'RE NOT
NEGOTIATING. OUR SALARIES BUT
REALLY IF WE HAVE SALARY
TRANSPARENCY IN WERE POSTING
SALARIES AND WOMEN ARE GETTING
PAID FOR WHAT THE POSITION PAYS
THAT'S- ADDRESSING THE SYSTEMIC.
BECAUSE. TO ANY OTHER. NO THANK
YOU BOTH VERY MUCH REALLY PRE
IT AND HOW THAT WE WILL CAN. TO
GET YOUR INPUT IS MEASURE MOVES.
SUMMER ARE. NICK PANEL OF
BRINGS FORWARD BUSINESS THERE
WHERE OLD LET'S SEE ONE TWO
THREE. OF FOUR PEOPLE ON THIS
PANEL SO WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU
EACH TO CUT YOUR TIME A BIT IN
HALF AND I ASSUME THEY'LL BE
SOME QUESTIONS BUT- THIS IS THE
ARE WERE WERE NOW BRINGING FOR
THE BUSINESS PERSPECTIVE- FROM
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY. THUS
FAR WE'VE GOTTEN A SENSE OF HOW
THE PINK TAX AFFECTS A
CONSUMER'S GENERALLY AND FEMALE
CONSUMERS OF SPECIFICALLY BUT-
ANY SOLUTION WILL HAVE TO HAVE
SOME IMPACT ON BUSINESSES AS
WELL SO. WE REALLY DO NEED AND
LOOK FORWARD TO THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY'S INPUT ON HOW WE CAN
BEST GO ABOUT ADDRESSING THIS
PROBLEM- AND I WANT TO SAY THAT
FIRST OFF THAT WHEN WE TRIED.
TO APPROACH THIS FROM A
HOLISTIC PERSPECTIVE- ON THE
EQUAL PAY BILLS- IT WAS A
PLEASURE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY AND I
KNOW WE HAVE A FOR. WOMEN HERE
REPRESENTING THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY WHICH IS ALWAYS GREAT
AND- MY GOOD FRIEND- MS
BARRETTE PRO FROM THE CHAMBER.
OF THIS BILL STARTS OFF I THINK
IS A JOB KILLER. I'M ALWAYS
HONORED TO BE ON THAT LIST BY
THE WAY- BUT HOPE. BUT HOPE
THAT WE CAN FIND A SOLUTION AS
WE DID WITH EQUAL PAY UP
BECAUSE THIS. HERE AND SO WE
HEAR YOUR PURSE WE HAVE AND
WE'LL START WITH HILLARY LANE
TEENY IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF WOMEN
BUSINESS OR PERSONAL. SHE'S ALL
THE FOR OF WOUND LEN TEAM
DESIGN AND MARK. SHE WILL BE
CHOI BY OF THE KEY TO POINT WHO
IS THE VICE PRESIDENT OF NOVELS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER. AND SHE IS
AN EXPERT ON HUMAN RESOURCES
AND THE PRINCIPLE BEHIND. AND
POINDEXTER CONSULTING GROUP I
LIKE THE SOUND CONSULTANT WE
HAVE A NEW TOP MEHTA WHO IS THE
TO. OF MARKETING AT BOXED DOT
COM WE HEARD A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
YOU A PREVIOUSLY AND- HAVE WITH
US ALL. SO JENNIFER. EGGS VICE.
OF THE CAL CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND I LIKE THE SOUND OF THE TO.
SO A LATE. WE HAD A HOPE TO
REDUCE TODAY FROM MAY WHO THE
PRESS OF THE CAL. READ AS A
RETAIL TO SO. UNFORTUNATELY SHE
ADDED TO IN THE- LAST WEEK'S.
SHE WAS ON ABLE TO ATTEND AND I
WANT TO EXTEND OUR COLLECT
CONDONE TO HER IN HER FOR AND
HOPE THAT. SHE WILL FIND
COMFORT IN THE GOOD MEMORIES
THAT SHE SHARED WITH HER
FAMILY- IN THAT WE WILL SEE HER
IN THE FUTURE AND TO HOPE TO
WORK WITH HER AS WE ADVANCE
THIS MEASURE SO. WE ARE NOT THE
WE ARE SADDENED THAT SHE WILL
BE WITH US BUT HOPE THAT IN THE
FUTURE WILL HEAR HER
PERSPECTIVE AND BE ABLE TO WORK
TOGETHER WITH HER SO. LET US
START WITH- HILLARY LENTINI
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF NOVEL. GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY.
SHARE OUR PERSON WITH YOUR- OF
NOT ONLY A EIGHT THE PRESIDENT
CAL BUT I'M THE PHONE OF NINETY
DESIGN IN MARKETING IN LOS
ANGELES I'M THE PAST OF THE LOS
ANGELES. AND PROUD TO BE
SERVING AS THE NOBLE CALIFORNIA
PRESIDENT AS WELL. AND. WITH ME
AS THE KEY TO HIS YOU KNOW.
WE'RE PARTNERS IN IN LEADERSHIP
FOR NOW A CALIFORNIA I LOOK FOR
TO HER AND WE ARE SO OUR TIME
HERE JUST SO YOU KNOW TO TRY TO
KEEP IT FOR YOUR REQUEST. THE
NATIONAL SAYS OF WOMEN BUSINESS
OWNERS BOB OKAY. REPRESENTS
OVER ONE AND A HALF MILLION
WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES IN ALL
INDUSTRIES ACROSS OUR STATE. SB
EIGHT SEVENTY THREE IS
CONSISTENT WITH CALIFORNIA'S
LONGSTANDING COMMITMENT TO
EQUITY FOR CONSUMERS FOR SIXTY
YEARS THE ON ROOF CIVIL RIVER
CIVIL RIGHTS ACT HAS PROHIBITED
BUSINESS ESTABLISHMENTS AND I
KNOW WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THEM A
LITTLE BIT BUT- THIS IS DOUBLE
THE LARGER POINT THAT I'M ABOUT
TO MAKE. HAS PRINT PROHIBITED
BUSINESS ESTABLISHMENTS FROM
DISCRIMINATING AGAINST ANY
INDIVIDUAL ON THE BASIS OF
CERTAIN CHARACTERISTICS SUCH AS
SEX RACE AND NATIONAL ORIGIN.
IN NINETY FIVE CALIFORNIA
ELABORATED ON THE UNDER ACT BY
ENACTING THE GENDER TAX REPEAL
ACT BY SPECIFICALLY BOOK
PROHIBITING BUSINESSES FROM
CHARGING FEMALE CONSUMERS
HIGHER PRICES. THAN MALE
CONSUMERS FOR SERVICES OF A
LIKE OR SIMILAR KIND UNLESS THE
PRICE DIFFERENTIALS COULD BE
JUSTIFIED ON NON DISCRIMINATORY
GROUND SUCH AS THE AMOUNT OF
TIME DIFFICULT- COST INVOLVED.
THE GENDER REPEAL THE GENDER
TAX REPEAL ACT WAS AN IMPORTANT
FIRST STEP. TOWARD GREATER
ECONOMIC EQUITY FOR FEMALE
CONSUMERS IN CALIFORNIA HOWEVER
THAT ACTED NOT PREVENT
BUSINESSES FROM CHARGING
DISCRIMINATORY PRICES FOR GOODS
AND I KNOW WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
THAT HERE BUT AS A RESULT IN
TOO MANY INSTANCES. CALIFORNIA
FEMALE CONSUMERS CONTINUE TO
PAY MORE THAN MALE CONSUMERS
FOR THE SAME PRODUCTS WE NOTE
SB EIGHT SEVENTY THREE WOULD
ADDRESS THE SHORT COMING IN THE
LAW. AND FULLY REPEAL THE
GENDER TAX. THE GATHERED BY
THESE COMMITTEE CONSUMER
PROTECTION GOVERNMENT
EFFICIENCY AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. SHOWS THE GENDER
DISCRIMINATION AND PRICING
RESULT IN EACH ADULT WOMAN IN
THIS STATE PAYING A GENDER TAX
OF APPROXIMATELY TWO THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE
DOLLARS EVERY YEAR. WOULD YOU
MULTIPLY THAT OUT ACROSS A
WOMAN'S WORKING LIFETIME. THEN
THE TOTALS OVER NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER FEMALE
CONSUMER. NOW WE'RE FROM THE
BUSINESS PERSPECTIVE SO IT'S
EVEN LONGER JUST AS THE FEMALE
CONSUMER FROM CRADLE TO GRAVE
BUT- OUR CONSERVATIVE ESTIMATE
WAS. SHE'S A WORKING WOMAN OR
AN ENTREPRENEUR FROM TWENTY TO
SIXTY SO THAT'S FORTY YEARS AND
THAT'S NINETY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR THAT FEMALE
BUSINESS OWNER. IS DIRECTLY
IMPACTS WOMEN ENTREPRENEURS IN
TERMS OF FUNDING THEIR OWN
BUSINESSES. MULTIPLE STUDIES
SHOW THAT WOMEN RECEIVE ONLY
TWO POINT 2% OF THE ENSURE
CAPITAL AND ANGEL FUNDING TWO
POINT 2% SO MOST OF THE WOMEN
HAVE TO FUND THEIR HELP PARTY
AS WELL THE AVERAGE ALONG FOR
WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES IS 31%
LESS THE MALE OWNED BUSINESSES
SO WOMEN ENTREPRENEURS OFTEN
FUND THEIR NASCENT BUSINESSES
AND THEY'RE GOING BUSINESSES
OUT OF THEIR OWN PERSONAL FUNDS
IN THEIR OWN POCKETS. 40% OF
WOMEN ENTREPRENEURS PULL FROM
THE PERSONAL SAVINGS FORTY
PERCENT. AND FORTY SIX OF THEM
USE THEIR PERSONAL CREDIT CARDS
TO FUND THEIR BUSINESSES. IN
THE QUEUE TO WILL BE TAKING
OVER ON OUR UP THE BACK HALF OF
OUR TIME. THANK YOU MS
POINDEXTER. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. I'M AS HILLARY
INDICATED I AM PRESIDENT ELECT
FOR NOVEL CALIFORNIA I AM
CURRENTLY THE PRESIDENT OF THE
AND WHEN EMPIRE. THE CLOSELY OF
OUR. THE ONLY MOVIE BACK OVER
OKAY. OKAY SO AGAIN I'M THE
KING POINDEXTER IN THE PRESS
ELECT FOR NOVEL CAL I AM THE OF
THE INLAND EMPIRE I AM AND CEO
APPOINT CONSULTING GROUP WHICH
IS HEADQUARTERED IN TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA. I WANT TO KIND OF.
JUST REALLY TALK REALLY BRIEF
REGARDING SOME CONCERNS THAT I
HAVE REGARDING THIS RECOGNIZING
THAT THERE IS A GENDER PAY GAP
IS RELEVANT HERE ACCORDING TO
THE STUDY BY THE CENTER FOR THE
ADVANCEMENT OF WOMEN AT MOUNT
SAINT MARY'S UNIVERSITY THAT
WAS JUST PUBLISHED RECENTLY IT
IS TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN REPORT
ON THE STATUS OF WOMEN AND
GIRLS IN CALIFORNIA. WOMEN IN
THIS STATE MAKE EIGHTY NINE
CENTS FOR EVERY DOLLAR MEN EARN.
AND AMONG WOMEN OF COLOR TO
SPIRIT SEE IS MORE GLARING. FOR
EACH DOLLAR EARNED BY OUR WHITE
MALE COUNTERPARTS ASIAN
AMERICAN WOMEN EARN SEVENTY
FIVE CENTS. AFRICAN AMERICAN
WOMEN WE ARE SIXTY CENTS AND
LATINA WOMEN AREN'T FORTY THREE
PER SENSE. WHEN YOU FACTOR IN
GENDER BASED DISCRIMINATORY
TAXES THAT COSTS THE FEMALE
CONSUMER AS HILLARY INDICATED
AN AVERAGE OF NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS OVER HER
WORKING LIFE TIME WITH GENDER
PAY GAP. FEMALE CONSUMERS ARE
FURTHER EQUITY CHALLENGE.
CAUGHT IN A REALITY OF
DISCRIMINATORY PRICING BEST
SYSTEMICALLY AS SYSTEMATICALLY
DEPRIVES WOMEN HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY AND EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY TO SUCCEED. THE
BOTTOM LINE HERE IS THAT ANY
FORM OF GENDER BASED TACK TAX
UNDERMINES THE ABILITY OF WOMEN
BUSINESS OWNERS. TO COMPETE ON
A LEVEL PLAYING GROUND. WE ARE
PLEASED TO BE INVOLVED IN THE
INITIAL CONVERSATIONS TO
RECTIFY THIS AND ARRIVE AT A
SOLUTION. THANK CLOSING WOULD
LIKE TO PARAPHRASE THE
TRAILBLAZING RBG. WE ASK NO FOR
OUR GENDER. WELL WE- OF OUR IN
IS THAT THEY TAKE FEET OFF OUR
NECKS THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
MUCH GREAT. HIS PEREIRA ARE THE
XP REPRESENT THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND- IF YOU WOULD
LIKE- TEN MINUTES OR SO TO
SPEAK WE ARE ALTHOUGH YOU SPEAK
SO FAST MAYBE A SLOW DOWN SLOW
TODAY YEAH RIGHT COULD.
THREATEN MY LUXURY OF HAVING
TEN MINUTES I'LL GO SLOW THREE-
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON THIS
AND TO OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IT'S GREAT TO BE
HERE- I'M GOING TO- I FOR
SIGNAL AJ THE GENDER PAY GAP
WHICH HAS BEEN A CENTRAL FOCUS
OF THIS DISCUSSION AND GIVEN
THE GOOD WORK OF SENATOR
JACKSON'S SEVERAL YEARS AGO
WHERE WE ARE ABLE TO PARTNER ON
THAT. I JUST ALSO READ REPORT
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS THE
NARROWEST WAGE GAP OUT OF THE
ENTIRE CUT SO KUDOS TO SENATOR
JACKSON ON THAT EVEN THOUGH
THERE'S STILL A DISCREPANCY SO
I WANT TO MAKE A VERY IMPORTANT
PART ON THAT LEGISLATION THAT
WE ARE ABLE TO PARTNER TOGETHER
GENDER THOUGH GENDER
LEGISLATION THAT SHE COVERED
DIDN'T SAY THERE WAS ABSOLUTELY
HAD TO BE EQUAL PAY WITH NO
FACTORS THERE IS BONA FIDE
FACTORS UPON WHICH YOU COULD
HAVE A DISCREPANCY. CENTS TO
THE DOLLAR AND WHETHER OR NOT
THOSE THAT DISCREPANCY IS
ACTUALLY BASED UPON BUT A FIGHT
FACTORS SUCH AS YOUR LONGEVITY
AT THE JOB SUCH AS EXPERIENCE
SUCH AS EDUCATION AND THERE IS
EVEN A DISCUSSION ABOUT
GEOGRAPHICAL DIFFERENCES AND
WHY THAT COULD JUSTIFY A WAGE
DIFFERENCE AND THAT WASN'T
GOING TO BE COMPLETELY EQUAL
SO- THAT'S ONE ASPECT THAT I
WANT TO DRESS BUT I'M ALSO
GOING TO PUSH BACK ON. AND
DISAGREE WITH SOME OF THE-
POINTS THAT WERE MADE EARLIER
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF COMMENTS
THAT THE GENDER PRICE IS
DISCRIMINATION OR THAT IS A
CIVIL RIGHTS VIOLATION AND I
WANT TO KIND OF PUSH BACK ON
THAT NOTION FOR A MOMENT WE ARE
NOT TALKING ABOUT A SITUATION
HERE IN WHICH I'M GOING UP TO
THE REGISTER AND SENATOR HILL
IS GOING UP TO THE REGISTER
WITH THE PINK TEDDY BEAR. AND
THEY'RE LOOKING AT ME IN THEIR
SAME BECAUSE YOU'RE A WOMAN
WE'RE GOING TO PAY OUR TO
REUIRE YOU TO PAY TWO DOLLARS
MORE FOR THAT EXACT SAME
PRODUCT THAN SENATOR HILL NO
WE'RE EACH PAIN THE EXACT SAME
PRICE REGARDLESS OF OUR GENDER
AND IT COMES DOWN TO WE CHOICE
THAT IS VERY DIFFERENT THAN A
CIVIL RIGHTS VIOLATION WHERE
YOU'RE GOING TO A PLACE OF
PUBLIC ACCOMMODATION AND THE
OWNER OF THE BUSINESS THE SAME.
BECAUSE OF YOUR GENDER YOU
CANNOT YOU CANNOT HAVE SERVICE
HERE BECAUSE OF YOUR GENDER
MUCH LIKE A SENATOR EXCUSE ME
MY RESPONSE WHO SAID BECAUSE OF
YOUR CHEN ACTUALLY GOING TO OUR
CHART PRICE THAT'S NOT WHAT IS
HAPPENING WITH THE GOODS IF YOU
GO UP WITH THE EXACT SAME GOOD
TO THE REGISTER REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER YOU'RE MALE OR FEMALE
YOU'RE BEING CHARGED THE SAME
PRICE AND SO I HAVE A HARD TIME
ACCEPTING THAT THIS IS
DISCRIMINATION IN THE NORMAL
WAY IN WHICH WE USE THAT TERM.
OR THAT IT'S A CIVIL RIGHTS
VIOLATED BECAUSE REGARDLESS OF
YOUR GENDER YOU'RE PAYING THE
SAME PRICE IT COMES DOWN TO
CHOICE THE OTHER NOTION THAT
ALL PUSH BACK ON A LITTLE BIT
IS IT WITH REGARDS TO EVEN
LABELING THE SUBPOENA AXE
REINFORCING STEREO TYPES AT THE
GROUP OF US TALKED ABOUT THAT
PINK IS FOR GIRLS AND LOUIS
FOR. A KIND OF. IT YEAH. I HAVE
A- OF TIME. WE HEARD WE HEARD
TO IN TO I THINK IT REINFORCES
OUT DAY NOTION IN THOSE DATE IF
TIE THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN IS.
WITH THE SPUR GENDER AND SO
WE'RE BASICALLY SO THAT ANY CAN
HAS TO BE PRICED AT THE SAME AS
A BELOW WHICH IS A VERY CA. NO
THAT WERE RE AND THOSE TO TYPES
IN OUR MARKET I ALSO WANT TO
PUSH ON THE NEW. OF A OF THAT
THIS S NOT IN THE SENSE OF
THERE'S AN UNDERMINING. THAT A
FEMALE CONSUMER IS NOT EDUCATED
ENOUGH TO MAKE A CONSCIOUS
DECISION ABOUT WHICH PRODUCT
THEY'RE GOING TO PURCHASE I
AGREE MOST WOMEN ARE THE CFO'S
OF THEIR FAMILIES AND CFO'S OF
THEIR HOUSEHOLD AND THEY ARE
MAKING THE MAJORITY OF THE
PURCHASES. BUT THEY'RE ALSO
EXTREMELY EDUCATED AND THEY'RE
ALSO WOULD BE ABLE TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT MY INCOME IS
WORTH THAT PRODUCT WHETHER OR
NOT I'M WILLING TO PAY THAT
AMOUNT FOR THAT SPECIFIC
PRODUCT AND IT REALLY IT COMES
DOWN TO IT BUT THE PINK
FREEZERS EXACT SAME AS THE BLUE
RAZOR. AND I DON'T GET THAT
PRICE THE CONCERT I HAVE THAT
CHOICE I'M AT EIGHT IN THIS
TICKET ENOUGH TO DETERMINATION
AS A CONSUMER SO I PUSH BACK ON
THAT OKAY CAN WE TALK TO NEW
YORK'S. THE STATE THAT A WITH
THINK IT AS ENERGY MENTIONED
PROXIMAL. PRODUCTS THE
MARKETPLACE COMPARISON. THE
PRISON AT THOSE ARE I AM I DO
THAT IN THE DIFFERENCE AND
DISTINCTIONS THAT YOU CAN EVEN
TELL JUST FROM THE AT THE OF
THE FOR A- I THINK THERE WAS
LIKE A COMPARISON OF TO SKI
JEANS ONE. HI ENOUGH THE OTHER
LIKE I WOULD THE DOW SOMETHING
SOME BILLS ON THE TOOLS FOR
WILL PROBABLY COST MORE. AS FAR
AS BIRD AND MATERIALS AND IT
WAS PURPOSE TO FOR. NONE THE
LESS LET'S JUST ASSUME ALL
THOSE PRODUCTS ARE SAME MY- IS
THAT THAT WAS TAKEN IN WE NOT
SHOT OF MARKET OUT. IN THE MARK.
BUT OVER THE- AIR MARK. NOT
WHAT IN THOSE THOSE PROP AT
THAT TIME ONE MAY HAVE BEEN
HIGHER THE OTHER BUT IF YOU
LOOK AT A COUPLE FROM THERE
MAYBE THE PRICE FLEX SO WHY
THOSE WHAT AND WHAT HOW WITH
THE FUNCTION WELL THERE'S A
VERY OF READY REASONS THAT GO
INTO THE PRICING FOR THE MANY
IT CAN BE THE THAT ARE PURCHASE
IT CAN BE TERRACE AS WE'VE SEEN
YOUR ABILITY TO GET PRODUCTS
FROM OTHER FROM IMPORTING FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES CAN BE EVENT
SUCH AS A WHAT PARENTS IN OVER
IN CHINA WITH THE CORONA. LEAD
TO GET ACCESS. THIRTY PRICE
START. TENS ON HOW MY PURCHASE
OF THAT'S MATERIAL SO PRODUCTS
AMMAR OF SKILL IF IT'S A MARK
OF SCALING YOUR PURCHASE A
LARGE THE- THEN IT'S GOING TO
BE TO THAN A YOUR PURCHASE AS
MARK OF SCALE IT GOES INTO
ANGRY FOR. CAN IN A DISH
INGREDIENTS THAT IS MORE
APPEALING TO THE CONSUMER AND
ALSO COST MORE TO INCLUDE
PACKED. SB THREE CURRENT
DOESN'T ALLOW PACKAGING AS A
PER TO. A KEY COST MORE
MARKETING ADVERTISING ON A
SPECIFIC PRODUCT ALL OF THOSE
COSTS ARE ARE PUT INTO THE
FINAL COST THAT THE
MANUFACTURER MAY PROVIDE TO THE
RETAILER. AND THEN YOU GET IT
TO THE RETAIL AND WHAT ARE THE
COST AND FACTORS IN THAT. IT
CAN BE ON YOUR INVENTORY IF YOU
HAVE A HIGH INVENTORY AT
SOMETHING IN A LOW INVENTORY ON
ANOTHER THING THAT WILL IMPACT
THE PRICE. IF YOU'RE RUNNING
SALES IF YOU'RE RUNNING COUPONS
IF YOU HAVE DIFFERENT OPTIONS
AVAILABLE IN THE IN THE RETAIL
WITH REGARDS TO THE PRODUCTS
OFFER YOU'RE GOING TO THAT WILL
IMPACT THE- PRICE AND SO YOU.
OF ALL THESE FLUCTUATIONS OF
PRICE SECOND HAPPEN OVER THE
ENTIRE MARKET CYCLE SO TO ONE
NOW. OF THE MARKET AND HEY BE A
PROBLEM FOR MORE ACTIVE ALSO
CONCERNING THEIR FEDERAL
STUDIED WAS JUST FINISHED A-
PUBLISHED IN AUG. OF TWO
EIGHTEEN I BELIEVE WHERE THEY
ALSO LOOK AT ABOUT TEN PERSONAL
OR PRODUCTS. AND THEY DIDN'T
OVER TWO WEEKS SO A LITTLE BIT
LONGER THAN WHAT I BELIEVE THE
NEW YORK STUDY WAS AND THE TO
YORK CYCLE. SHOW THAT PRODUCTS
WHICH WOULD LABEL AS FOR MEL.
THEY WERE TIRED ALSO MAILED
SEPARATE TIRE AND THEN THERE
WERE ROLE THAT. THE REAL
DIFFERENCE. I BUT THERE. BE IN
A- OVER TOP. THE PRODUCT PLAY
TO WHICH THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
APPLY AND HOW THE WOULD WORK I
THE OTHER POINT I WON TO TALK
IS THE IN MECHANISM WHICH
CENTER JACK'S AND I OFF
DISAGREE UPON THERE WAS A
DISCUSSION ON WITH COME. SPEAR
OF HER BILL WHICH IS THE
GENDERS SO TO ELECT AND THAT IS
KERN ENFORCED UNDER CIVIL CODE
FIFTY TWO WHERE OUT OUR STATUTE
AND IT PROVIDES THAT YOU CAN
BRING A PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
WITH A MINIMUM OF FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS STATUTORY DAMAGES
MEANING THAT EVEN IF THERE IS A
PENNY DIFFERENCE IN THE PRICE.
THE MINIMUM AMOUNT YOU IS FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND THERE IS A
DISCUSSION OF WHETHER OR NOT
THERE HAS BEEN LOCATION THERE
HAS. IT WAS A VERY FAMOUS
ACTUALLY ARE WIDELY REPORTED
ISSUE DOWN IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
IN WHICH- AN ATTORNEY AND HIS
GIRLFRIEND TARGETED FIVE
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES DRY
CLEANERS HAIR STYLISTS. AND
WHEN IN THERE AND PURCHASE THE
SERVICES. AND THE I BELIEVE AT
THE DRY CLEANER ALTHOUGH I WILL
VERIFY IT WAS A TWENTY FIVE
CENT DIFFERENCE AND THEY ASK
FOR OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS- WITH THE PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION NOW. THOSE CASES THEY
WERE LITIGATED FOUND AN
ATTORNEY TO. OUT IN THE
ATTORNEY WHO FILED THOSE CASES
WAS ULTIMATELY PUT IN JAIL
WHICH IS GREAT. NONE THE LESS
THE OTHER STATION WAS FILED IN
THE- WAS PRESENTED. THERE'S A
PUBLISHED CASES IN EACH. OF OUR
WALMART CASE A MALE CUSTOMER
NGUYEN IN AND ASKED FOR AN OIL
SO. OIL CHANGE THAT DATE ON A-
DAY WHEN THEY'RE PROVIDING
ACTUALLY A DISCOUNT TO WOMEN
FOR OLD. AND THEY FILED A
LAWSUIT AND THE GENDER SERVICES
TAX REPEAL LACKS AND IT WAS
UNFAIR AND DISCRIMINATORY. TO
THE MEN THAT THE WOMEN WERE
GETTING A DISOUNT THERE WAS
ANOTHER ONE WITH REGARDS TO A
GOLF COURSE WHERE THEY ARE
AGAIN PROVIDING A LADIES DAY
OPPORTUNITY THERE WAS ANOTHER
ONE WITH REGARDS TO A DATING
SITE IN WHICH THEY'RE
PROVIDING. A DISCOUNTED SERVICE
RATE FOR WOMEN VERSUS MEN AND
SO WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE
SUBJUGATION. IS THAT ANYBODY
CAN FILE THE LAWSUIT SO LET'S
GO BACK TO THE EXAMPLE OF THE
PINK RESERVE VERSUS THE BLUE
RESEARCH. LET'S SEE IN THAT
EXAMPLE THE BLUE RAZOR WAS
CAUGHT. HIGHER PRICE IN THE
PANCREAS. UNDER THIS PROPOSAL
THE MAIL COULD GO IN THROUGH
THE RETAILER IN SAY I WAS
CHARGED. YOUR PRICE FOR THE MY
BLUE RAZOR WHICH IS MALE AND SO
I SHOULD BE ABLE TO BE ENTITLED
TO A MINIMUM OF FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS. THAT'S A HUGE CONCERN
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE IN THAT
FEDERAL STUDY THAT I MENTIONED
BEFORE. THERE'S OTHER
JURISDICTIONS WHO HAVE ENACTED
SIMILAR TYPE LEGISLATION THEY
MENTION CALIFORNIA REGARD THE
CHEN TAX. REPEAL ACT MIAMI DADE
COUNTY I BELIEVE- ALSO HAS A
LOT WITH REGARDS TO JURORS TO.
IN FOR BY AGO AGING. DO I'M- IN
IT TO WIN I TAKE. NEST EITHER
THOSE OF FOR PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION. REBUTTALS TO THAT- IN
LOOK FOR TO THAT OPPORTUNITY
BUT LET US FINISH WITH OUR-
NEXT SPEAKER WHO IS NATASHA
META. FROM BOX DOT COM. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THE SIX MINUTES
IF YOU CUT. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE OF FOR
PROVIDING THIS OPPORTUNITY- FOR
ME TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY HERE
TODAY. MY NAME IS NATASHA ****
AND I AM A MARKETING DIRECTOR
AT FOX IF YOU HAVEN'T HEARD OF
BOX WE ARE THE ONLINE AND
MOBILE VERSION OF THE WHOLE SO
SHOPPING CLUB BUT WITH NO
MEMBERSHIP FEES AND FREE
SHIPPING. WE A HELP OUR
CUSTOMERS SAVE TIME AND MONEY
AND WILL EVEN DELIVER A BOOK
SIZE ESSENTIALS TO CALIFORNIA
IN TWO DAYS. EQUALITY IS
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TO ME AND ALL OF US THAT BOX
AND THAT IS THE REASON WE
DECIDED TO TAKE A STAND AND
LAUNCH OUR RETHINK PINK
INITIATIVE AND IN OCTOBER OF
TWENTY SIXTEEN. QUITE FRANKLY I
WAS FED UP WITH THE GLARING
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST WOMEN
WHO WERE FORCED TO PAY HIGHER
PRICES FOR THE SAME PRODUCTS.
SO WE TOOK A HARD LOOK AT SOME
OF THE PRODUCTS OFFERED ON THE
BOX. AND REALIZE THAT MANY
FEMALE PRODUCTS COST
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE THAN THEIR
MALE EQUIVALENTS MADE BY THE
SAME MANUFACTURER THE SAME
BRANDS. ON A PER ALLEN'S ARE
PER UNIT BASIS. THIS IS BASED
ON THE COSTS THAT WE RECEIVE
THAT WE RETAILERS RECEIVE FROM
RESERVE CREATED BY THE SAME
MANUFACTURER MAY COST AT TWO
HUNDRED AND 8% MORE. ON A PER
UNIT BASIS FOR THE FEMALE
VERSION VERSES THE MALE
VERSION. EVEN THOUGH THE MEN'S
RAZOR MAY BE SHARPER AND THAT
AND THE BLADE MAYBE A BETTER
QUALITY. WHEN I INITIALLY BUT
AT THIS ISSUE TO OUR FOR CO
FOUNDERS FOR MEN- IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN THEY DIDN'T UNDERSTAND
WHY OR HOW THIS COULD BE THE
CASE BACK. FOUR YEARS AGO IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN. ARE CHAU CHE
WAN WAS JUST AS SHOCKED AS I
WAS TO LEARN ABOUT THESE
PRICING DISCREPANCIES. HE
HIMSELF HAS A YOUNG DAUGHTER
AND HE DIDN'T UNDERSTAND WHY OR
HOW SHE WOULD HAVE TO PAY MORE
ON ESSENTIAL ITEMS. THROUGHOUT
HER LIFETIME THAT HER MALE
FRIENDS WOULD HAVE TO. AND SO
WITHIN TWO WEEKS AND WITH THE
ENTIRE COMPANY SUPPORT.BOX
DECIDED TO TAKE A STAND AND
LOWER PRICES ON WOMEN'S
PRODUCTS THAT HAD A SIGNIFICANT
COST VARIANCE VERSES THEIR MALE
EQUIVALENT. AS WELL AS REDUCE
OUR PRICES ON TAMPONS AND PADS
IN AN EFFORT TO OFFSET THE
SALES TAX EVEN IF THIS MEN'S
TAKING AHEAD ON MARGIN. AS A
RESULT THE BOX BECAME THEFIRST
AND ONLY NATIONAL RETAILER TO
TAKE A STAND ON GENDER PRICING
INEQUITIES. WE WERE THE ONLY
ONE TO DO SO IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
AND TODAY IN TWENTY TWENTY WE
ARE STILL THE ONLY NATIONAL
RETAILER TAKING A STAND. SINCE
WE'VE LAUNCHED WE'VE HAD
MILLIONS OF VISITORS TO OUR
LANDING PAGE AND ART EDUCATION-
HAVE HAD TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
NEW CUSTOMERS SIGN UP FOR A BOX
AS A RESULT OF OUR INITIATIVE.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY WE'VE PASS
OVER ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF SAVINGS BACK
BRANDS HAVE LAUNCHED IN
RESPONSE TO THE PAYING TAX AND
OUR HOPE IS THAT BRANDS LIKE
BEES WILL CONTINUE TO GAIN
STEAM AND PUT PRESSURE ON
LARGER MANUFACTURERS THAT STILL
PARTICIPATE IN GENDER PRICING
DISCRIMINATION. BILL IS SO
CRITICAL FOR HOLDING THESE
LARGER MANUFACTURERS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR CHANGING
DISCRIMINATORY PRICING ONCE AND
FOR ALL. CALIFORNIA HAS A
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO BE ONE OF
THE LEADERS TO PUSH FORWARD
BETTER ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY IN THIS INDUSTRY.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN THIS
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
AND THANK YOU- I DO HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS- DOES ANYBODY HAVE
ANY TO GET STARTED OR WOULD YOU
LIKE ME TO START. AGO OKAY KOKO
HEAD THAT WELL- LET LET ME
START WITH YOU MS MADE UP. YOU
KNOW VERY INTERESTING ID WE
HEAR AND WE HEARD FROM OUR GOOD
FRIENDS AT THE CHAMBER ABOUT
HOW. YOU KNOW WOMEN. WE WERE
SOPHISTICATED BUYERS AND WE
SHOULD KNOW WHEN WE'RE MAKING A
CHOICE- IN YOUR EXPERIENCES
THAT ACTUALLY ACCURATE. IT'S A
YES OF COURSE WOMEN-
SOPHISTICATED BUYERS BUT THESE
ITEMS ARE NOT NECESSARILY NEXT
TO EACH OTHER AND SO WHEN
YOU'RE GOING THROUGH THAT AND
I'LL IT ARE YOUR GROCERY STORE
YOU EAT YOUR RETAILER. THE
WOMEN'S RAZORS ARE NOT OFTEN
RIGHT NEXT TO THE MEN'S VERSION
AND SO. WOMEN ARE NOT COMPARING
THOUGH WOMEN'S VERSIONS VERSUS
THE MALE VERSION THAT THEY WERE
THEY PROBABLY WOULD USE THAT
CHEAPER OPTIONS BUT GENERALLY
IF THOSE OPTIONS ARE NOT
PRESENTED TO THEM. CLEAR AWAY
EITHER IN STORE OR ONLINE
EITHER I'M AT I NEED THE OTHER
ASPECT OF THAT IS MARKETING AS
WELL AND SO IS SPECIFIC BRANDS
ARE MARKETED TO WOMEN IS NOT
NECESSARILY THE PAYING FOR SINS
BLUE BUT THE SPECIFIC BRAND OF
RAZOR IS THAT IS MARKETED TO
WOMEN THAT IS USED BY WOMEN. IN
THEIR ADS VERSES SIMILARLY A
TARGETED AT MEN'S RATE THAT ARE
TARGETED TO MATT AND SO.
CONSUMERS NO- AND SEE THESE
PRODUCTS- AND ASSOCIATE THEM
WITH MALE VERSUS FEMALE SO HOW
DOES BOXED A DOT COM DETERMINE
WHEN TWO PRODUCTS ARE
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR ENOUGH
THAT A PINK TAX DISCOUNT IS
WARRANTED AND HAVE AN A
MANUFACTURES EVER CHALLENGE
THAT DETERMINATION NO WE
ACTUALLY WE A PURCHASE THESE
PRODUCTS FROM OUR MANUFACTURERS
AT A COSTS AND THEY HAVE COME
TO REALIZE THAT THEY DO HAVE
PRICING DISCRIMINATION FROM
THEIR COSTS ON THEIR SIDE AS
WELL AND MANY OF THEM HAVE
SUPPORTED US- EITHER THROUGH
DONATIONS ETCETERA BECAUSE THEY
ARE UNABLE TO CHANGE THE COSTS
ON THEIR END BUT THEY DO WANT
TO SUPPORT. OUR INITIATIVE- SO
HOW DO YOU DETERMINE WHEN THOSE
TWO THOSE TWO PRODUCTS ARE
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR TO GIVE
THAT THAT DISCOUNT THE WILL
LOOK AT THE PRODUCTS COSTS ON
EITHER PER UNITS ARE PER OUNCE
BASIS AND SO IT IS THE SAME
FACTURE THAT IS PRODUCING TO
THE SAME VERY SIMILAR ITEMS- AS
LONG AS THEY ARE SIMILAR IN
NATURE IN TERMS OF ZERO USE-
DISPOSABLE VERSUS NOT AS LONG
WHAT WE WILL AND CONSIDER THAT
BALANCES ARE A UNITS- THAT
PACKAGING AND THE TERM
DETERMINE. WHETHER THE NEEDS IT
JUST SAID SO WITH TO. YOUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH A MAN HAVE
EVER BEEN ABLE TO THEM OUT OF
TRYING TO PASS ALONG THESE.
DESPARD SIS YEAR CUSTOMERS OR
IN GENERAL SO SINCE WE A
LAUNCHER INITIATIVE IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN WE NO LONGER A SORTS
ARE BRING ON ANY ITEMS I DO YOU
HAVE PRICING DISCRIMINATION OUR
GENDER PRICING DISCRIMINATION
AND SO WE ACTUALLY WORKED WITH
A- POPULAR BRANDS- THAT BROUGHT
US TO OPTIONS OF BODY WASH ONE-
WOMEN'S BODY WASH- AND- ONE WAS
A MEN'S VERSION. OF THE SAME
BODY WASH- THAT HAD SEPARATE
COSTS AND WE A I ASKED THE
MANUFACTURE WHY THEY THEY WERE
PRICED SEPARATELY AND THEY
COULDN'T ANSWER THAT QUESTION
FOR US. AND THEY ENDED UP
GIVING US THE SAME COSTS FOR
BOTH. INTERESTING SO- LAST
QUESTION- HOW DO YOU DETERMINE
WHEN A PRODUCT IS BEING
MARKETED TO TWO WOMEN IN
PARTICULAR ANOTHER WORKS. WHAT
IF A MANUFACTURER'S CHARGING
DIFFERENT PRICES FOR WHAT
APPEAR TO BE THE SAME PRODUCT.
BUT THERE'S NO BASIS FOR
THINKING THAT THE DIFFERENCES
BASED ON GENDER. THOUGH SOME
MARKETING ITSELF AND GENERALLY
IT'S A SOMEONE WHO IS CHAU HUNT
IN THOSE IN THAT MARKETING TELL
SENATE. OF THE LARGEST ADAM.
AND ALL HER NAME. AS WELL
THERE'S- SOCIAL CHANNELS AND IT
WHO IS AT HIS. THANK OUR A PART
IN THOSE I DEAF MEDIA. AS WELL
AS WHO THERE'S TO AND SO IF
THERE SHOWING A WOMAN BIRCH AND
SHE HER LAN VERSUS A MALE SHE
HIS THAT IS A PRETTY.
SIGNIFICANT AS PRETTY TARGETED
POINT TO. GENDER AND ESOS WITH
THAT HEY. THAT'S CORRECT I
THINK OF IT ON TV SEEING A
RAZOR WITH THE WOMAN OF NICE.
OF RAZOR IN A PAIR OF LEGS
SHAVING- AND THEN YOU GET THE
MAN WITH THE SCRUFFY BEARD AND
ALL IN THAT RAZORS DEFINITELY
NOT PINK HEY YEAH- ALTHOUGH THE
ONE FOR THE WOMEN IN THIS YEAH-
SO- ALL RIGHT A ANY QUESTIONS
FOR MS MADE. BUT ONE OF THANK
YOU FOR YOUR EFFORT AND I'M
JUST WANTING IT YOU MENTION
THERE ARE NO OTHER COMPANIES
THAT YOU'RE AWARE OF THAT ARE
DOING THE SAME THING NATIONAL
RETAILERS THAT. THAT ARE DOING
THIS TODAY OUR GOAL IS TO GET
OTHER NATIONAL RETAILERS ON
BOARD WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT
WILL TAKE. AS SUPPORT FOR
MANUFACTURERS TODAY WE ARE
TAKING AHEAD ON MARGIN- WHICH
IS. AS WHICH IS THE MAIN ROAD
BLOCK FOR OTHER RETAILERS TO
GET ON BOARD. SO SUPPORT SO IF
WE WERE TO SAY TO MANUFACTURERS
AT SOME LAWFUL- YOU AND TO YOU
YOU KNOW THERE ARE CONSEQUENCES
TO THAT YOU THINK THAT THAT
WOULD. ABSOLUTELY HAVE AN
IMPACT THANK. ALRIGHT WELL I
WANTED TO ASK HIM IS BARRERA-
ALWAYS TEMPTING TO. ENGAGE YOUR
BUT VERY BRIEFLY- YOU KNOW YOU
ARTICULATED A FEW REASONS THE
BONA FIDE FACTORS AND WE DID
THERE'S WE DO THIS AND EQUAL
PAY BECAUSE IF THERE ARE
JUSTIFICATIONS THAT ARE NON
GENDER BASED THEIR LEGITIMATE-
BUT THE GENDER BASED
pDISCRIMINATION IS NOT
LEGITIMATE. I HEAR IN THE
SITUATION WITH THE PAIN TAX-
YOU INDICATE THINGS LIKE
TERRORISTS ADVANCE MARKET OF
SCALE THINGS OF THAT SORT THE
INGREDIENTS. I DON'T THINK
WE'RE I DON'T THINK THAT WERE
SAYING THAT THAT THOSE AREN'T
LEGITIMATE. DIFFERENCES I THINK
WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS WHEN THERE
IS REALLY NO. GERMAN DIFFERENCE
OR THAT YOU. MAKE THE PINK PROP
THE PACKAGING THE PINK PRODUCT
A LITTLE FANCIER BECAUSE YOU
WANT TO ATTRACT WOMEN TO IT.
THAT THAT IS A GENDER BASIS AND
THAT WOULD BE UNLAWFUL SO-
ASSUMING THAT WERE ON THE SAME
PAGE WITH THAT THAT THAT THERE
ARE BONA FIDE FACTORS AND I
THINK THAT THE WEEK WE ALL
AGREE WITH THAT- WHAT IS YOUR
OTHER OBJECTION TO- PROHIBITING
THIS KIND OF GENDER. GENDER
BASED DISCRIMINATION. WELL I
THINK IF WE GET I THINK. WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE BONAFIDE
FACTORS IN THE WAY IF WE CAN
JUST RELATE TO SB EIGHT SEVENTY
THREE. YES I ALWAYS SWITCH THE
NUMBERS ARE EIGHT SEVENTY
THREE- WITH THE PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION AND IF WE CAN TALK
ABOUT THAT FOR A MOMENT WITH A
MINIMUM OF FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN DAMAGES AND HOW THAT
GOES INTO THE BONA FIDE FACTORS
IF YOU'LL JUST GIVE ME A
MOMENT. THE BONA FIDE FACTORS
THAT'S ALL ONE. WHEN I THINK WE
NEED TO LOOK AT HOW DO WE
DETERMINE WHAT IS SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR AND I THINK THAT'S A
HUGE CHALLENGE AND THE
PERSPECTIVE LOOK OF A CONSUMER
WHEN WE'RE SITTING HERE TALKING
ABOUT. IF THE CONSUMER IS GOING
TO BE LOOKING AT THE DIFFERENT
INGREDIENTS AND LOOKING AT THE
DIFFERENT PACKAGING AND BEING
ABLE TO TELL WHETHER THEY'RE
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR AND NOT
WHEN IT'S SUGGESTED THEY WON'T
EVEN GO FROM MILE TO I'LL DO
COMPARISON I THINK IS A HUGE
PROBLEM. WHEN CAN BE THE
ENFORCERS. BUT WE SAY OKAY.
THERE'S ACTUALLY SENT WHERE YOU
CAN HAVE A PER DIFFERENCE BASED
ON BOTH BUT FACT RATED AS YOU
MAY YOU LISTED THOSE OUT HERE'S
THE CHALLENGE. PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION THE MINIMUM FOR THAT
DOLLARS IF THE ELDER PLANE. AND
THEY SAY. IS THE SAME AS THE
BLU RAY. AND I PAID FOR CENTS.
AN THEY FOUND THAT LOS. AGAIN
THE RETAILER LEGISLATOR
RETAILER BECAUSE THAT'S THE PER
WHO THE- MOST LIKELY INTERACTS
WITH RATE- THE RETAILERS GOING
TO LOOK AT THAT. AND SAY I CAN
GO OUT AND HIRE AN ATTORNEY TO
DEFEND ME. FOR LET'S AT A CHEAP
DEFENSE FOR ALL THE WAY THROUGH
TROUT WOULD BE A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS I CAN GO
IMPAIR ATTORNEY TO DO THAT
RIGHT AND PAID THE DEFENSE. OR
I CAN SIT HERE IN NEGOTIATING
PAY THE MINIMUM FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS. AND PAY OFF THE
SETTLEMENT AND SETTLE THE CLAIM
NOW. THEY HAVE A BONA FIDE
FACTOR OF COURSE YOU WOULD WANT
TO GO AND DEFEND YOURSELF. OR
BUT WHEN YOU LOOKING THAT. THIS
DECISION. YOU'RE GONNA MAKE A
MOMENT AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THOUSANDS OF GOODS IN THE
MARKET PLACE. JUST HAVE BEEN.
TODAY AT THE- BILL TO. THREE
PRODUCT IN THE- PLACE. THAT'S A
CONCERN FOR A LOT OF BUSINESSES
SO JUST TO RESPOND BRIEFLY TO
THAT BECAUSE I KNOW THERE
MEMBERS UP HERE OR IN PERSON
THAT CONCEPT. WE HAVE A PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION NOW IN THE
INTERESTS OF RIGHTS ACT IT'S
BEEN THERE SINCE NINETEEN FIFTY
NINE. YOU YOU REFERRED TO-
NOTORIOUS A COUPLE IN- ORANGE
COUNTY WHEN. SO WE TOOK CARE
THAT PRETTY IN. IN THAT LAWYER.
LOST HIS. YOU KNOW LOST HIS
TICKET CAN NOT ONLY NO LONGER
PRACTICE LAW. ABOUT TO IS NOW
IN PRISON- WHAT WE'VE HEARD IS
THAT MOST OF THE DECISION
MAKING. IS DONE AT THE
MANUFACTURER'S LEVEL- SO IT
WON'T BE JUST AN ISOLATED
INCIDENT- AND- IS WE- HAVE
TALKED ABOUT SOME OF THESE.
OTHER ISSUES WHEN WE'RE TRYING
TO CREATE. AN A LEVEL PLAYING
FIELD AND A EQUITY LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD. WE HAVEN'T SEEN
A VAST NUMBER OF LAWSUITS. FROM
ANYWHERE. SO I KNOW YOU DON'T
LIKE PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
THINK THAT THAT OPENS THE
FLOODGATES. BUT I DON'T THINK
THAT THE- THE HISTORY. OF ANY
OF OUR EQUALITY EFFORTS HAVE
GENERATED THAT. THE REALITY
THAT YOU FEAR SO LET US ASSUME
FOR THE MOMENT. THAT YOU SAY
THERE'S A MINIMUM OF FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR EACH
ACTION. AND WE'RE LOOKING AT A
MANUFACTURER WHO'S MAKING. THE
OR SELLING THOUSANDS OF THESE
ITEMS. SO THAT FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS MAY BE VIEWED BY SOME
OF THESE COMPANIES AS A COSTS
DOING BUSINESS- AND WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR PRODUCT. AGAIN I AND WE
DID THIS THE COPAY YOU YOU
WEIGH THEM LET'S SAY HAVE A OF
PERFUME VERSUS AMEND COLOGNE.
AND YOU USE. DIFFERENT PRODUCTS
IN THEM. BUT THEY'RE ACTUALLY
PRODUCTS THE COST THE SAME
AMOUNT OF MONEY. SHOULD YOU BE
ABLE TO CHARGE MORE FOR THE
WOMAN'S PRODUCT VERSUS THE MANS
I WOULD POSIT NOW. IF ONE OF
THE IF THE COST OF THE ITEM IS
MORE EXPENSIVE THAT'S A
JUSTIFICATION BUT WHAT WE SEE
AND I KNOW THIS IS TRUE IN SOME
INSTANCES THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN MEN'S COLOGNE AND
WOMEN'S PERFUME. IS THE
PACKAGING. BUT THE COST IS
SIGNIFICANTLY DIFFERENT. IN IN
MANY INSTANCES- SO AGAIN THIS
WILL REQUIRE. A COMPANIES TO GO
BACK AND REVIEW THE DECISION
MAKING PRACTICES THEY HAVE. ARE
ARE YOU SUGGESTING THE COMPANY
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO DO THIS OR
SHOULDN'T BE. THAT IT WOULD BE
TOO BURDENSOME ON COMPANIES TO
DO THIS NOW I LOOK WHAT I'LL
SUGGEST IN JUST SICK KIND OF
ADDRESS SOME OF THE COMMENTS
THAT YOU- JUST PRESENTED BACK
ON THE LITIGATION FOR A MOMENT.
WE HAVE SEEN THE LITIGATION
BECAUSE THE OTHER CODE SECTION
THAT FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
STATUE OR STATUTORY DAMAGES
THAT'S ALSO THE CODE SECTION
THAT ENFORCES THE
ACCESSIBILITY- CASES THAT WE
HAVE SEEN THROUGHOUT THE STATE
HIT SMALL BUSINESS IN
PARTICULAR. AND THERE'S A MINOR
MINOR VIOLATIONS WITH REGARDS
TO A DOOR HANDLE WHICH I
APPRECIATE THE INTENT AND THE
AND THE NEED FOR DISABILITY
ACCESS I'M NOT SUGGESTING IN
ANY WAY THAT THAT'S NOT. A
SIGNIFICANT RIGHT BUT WHAT WE
SEE IS AGAIN THIS PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION WITH A MINIMUM OF
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
DAMAGES BEING UTILIZED TO
LEVERAGE QUICK SETTLEMENTS FROM
THE SMALL BUSINESSES WHY
DISAGREED THERE HAS BEEN A
SIGNIFICANT HISTORY. AND
EXAMPLES OF THE LAW TO BE. WITH
REPORTS TO CODES AND THAT EIGHT
SEP THREES. TO SURE SHOULD TO
MAKE THESE DETERMINE WITH
REGARDS TO PRICING BASED UPON
GEN. I DON'T THINK THAT AN
ALICE THAT GOES THE MANY. TODAY
AND I THINK THAT IF YOU WERE TO
HAVE A MANUFACTURER SITTING UP
HERE IN TESTIFYING INSANE WHAT
IS THE REASON WHY YOU'RE
CHARGING AN X. AMOUNT AMOUNT.
FOR THIS PROJECT IN A DIFFERENT
AMOUNT FOR THIS PROJECT THERE
WOULD BE A LIST OF COST
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE INGREDIENTS
CAN BE DIFFERENT I DON'T KNOW
THAT MEN'S COLOGNE IS THE SAME
AS WOMEN'S COLOGNE I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT THEY ARE DIFFERENT
AND FRAGRANCES AND SO I'M NOT
AN EXPERT ON. HOW IT'S MADE BUT
THE INGREDIENTS AND GOT TO BE
DIFFERENT BUT SECONDLY- THE
MARKETING THAT GOES INTO IT
ADVERTISING THAT GOES INTO IT
THAT'S ALL OF COSTS AS A PART
OF IT AND- MAYBE. MY SECOND I
PUT A HIGHER. PRICE OR A HIGH
VALUE ON PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
THAN MEN DO I'M SURE THAT MAY
BE A TENDER STEREO TYPE THAT I
JUST ASSERTED BUT I HAVE TO
BELIEVE TO SOME EXTENT THAT'S
TRUE MAYBE I'M WILLING AT THE
CONSUMER. TO PAY A HIGHER
AMOUNT FOR A CERTAIN PRODUCT A
CERTAIN BRAND A CERTAIN SMELL A
CERTAIN FRAGRANCE BECAUSE AS A
CONSUMER I VALUE THAT BUT THEN
PERHAPS AMANDA SO. THAT'S OF
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION IF I AM
PLEASED. THREE I IT AND I'LL
TRY AND BE MORE. I THINK WE
WILL OTHER OF MANY OTHER UP. TO
CAN. THIS CALL. ALWAYS
APPRECIATE YOUR PERSPECTIVE
AGAIN. PART OF THIS LEGISLATION
IS TO MAKE- COMPANIES
MANUFACTURERS MORE AWARE OF
THESE DIFFERENTIALS AND TO TAKE
TO MAKE A STATEMENT AS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT THIS
KIND OF. A DISCRIMINATION AND
PRICING IS NOT ACCEPTABLE SO WE
WILL CONTINUE THAT CONVERSATION
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SENATOR TO RISE- THANK YOU TO
ALL OF YOU FOR- FOR COMING AND
BEING A PART OF THIS. I REALLY
APPRECIATE- THE REMARKS BY THE
CESSATION NOT NOVEL- THANK YOU
BOTH VERY MUCH ABOUT FOR
CONNECTING WITH. THIS ISSUE
ABOUT THE PRODUCTS TO THE
BROADER ISSUE. WOMEN IN
BUSINESS AND- I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT BECAUSE I THINK
SOMETIMES WE CAN GET TO IN THE
WEEDS TOO MUCH IN THE DETAIL OF
WHAT PRODUCT OR ONE. VERY SMALL
PROBLEM AND THEN WE IGNORE
WHAT'S GOING ON MORE BROADLY.
AND THAT'S WHAT I'VE KIND OF
LEARNED TODAY IS THAT THERE IS
A CONNECTION WITHOUT THIS PANEL
I WOULD NOT HAVE MADE THE
CONNECTIO BACK TO. YOU KNOW
THE PAY GAP AND OTHER THINGS
ACCESS TO CAPITAL AS YOU ALL
ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
DIFFICULTY OF WOMEN- TO GET
INTO OF THE BUSINESSES THAT
THAT YOU REPRESENTS SO- I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THAT AND- I
THINK ALSO WITH- IS MET MATHIS.
MISS METHOD- IS IT COULD DOES
TO YOU FOR HAVING YOUR COMPANY
FOR HAVING THE COURAGE TO DO
THIS AND TAKE IT ON. I GUESS-
AND I ALSO MISSED IT I
APPRECIATE. WHAT YOU BRING TO
THE TABLE IT IT SEEMS TO ME
THOUGH THAT. WITH THIS ONE
SMALL STUDY IT HAS IDENTIFIED
SO MANY DIFFERENT PRODUCTS AND
JUST OUR OWN SORT OF DAY TO DAY
I REALLY WASN'T PAYING
ATTENTION TO THIS LIKE I DO I
STILL CAN'T BELIEVE THAT THEY
WOULD BE SUCH DIFFERENCES IN
PRICES- AND YOU KNOW I CONSIDER
MYSELF I TRY TO READ I TRY TO
STAY ON TOP OF ISSUES OF
FEMINIST AT. NIGHT OF IT'S
REALLY HARD TO BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS GOING ON RIGHT UNDER
OUR NOSES SO. I GUESS HOW. HOW
DO WE I THIS PARTICULAR
LANGUAGE OF THIS BILL FOR
EXAMPLE MS BUT IT IS- THERE'S A
PROBLEM WITH ENCOURAGING
LITIGATION THAT YOU MIGHT BE
SAYING. THERE IS A SYSTEMIC
PROBLEM HERE AND- AS WOMEN AS
MEN AND WOMEN. WERE CONSCIOUS
OF TRYING TO EQUALIZE OURSELVES
IN SOCIETY. WE WANT OUR-
DAUGHTERS AND I WILL MY
GRANDDAUGHTERS I JUST TEXTED MY
SON LIKE SOME OF THE PICTURES I
SAID DO YOU KNOW WHAT. WE NOT
BECAUSE I KNOW I LIVE IT EVERY
DAY. HE'S GOT TWO GIRLS BUT-
AND I'M JUST KIND OF RAMBLING
BUT IT'S HOW DO WE ADDRESS
THIS. BECAUSE IT IS RIGHT THERE
IT'S RIGHT THERE SO THERE'S
GOTTA BE A WAY OF ADDRESSING.
THE SYSTEMIC ISSUES. AND COME
UP WITH A WAY OF EITHER PUSHING
OUR EXAMPLE OF. IN I DON'T KNOW
WHAT IT IS TO CHANGE THE
BEHAVIOR OF COMPANIES WHO WHO
DO THIS. SO I REALLY QUESTION I
DON'T KNOW IF ANYBODY HAS A
COMMON AND RESPOND BUT
BASICALLY I APPRECIATE ALL OF
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SENATOR THANK BETTER CHAIR AND
THE I WHICH FOLLOW SENATOR
DIRAJA MOW IT AND SHE ALWAYS
ASK THE GREAT QUESTIONS THAT I
WAS THINKING OF BUT I WANTED TO
GET BACK TO AND I AGREE WITH
THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION THE
ISSUES RELATED TO THAT IN THE
ABUSES THAT WE'VE SEEN
SPECIALLY WITH ADA COMPLIANCE
AND THAT THE- SOME OF THE USES
OF THAT AND HOW THAT HAS BEEN
APPLIED AND- IN JUST TO. IT
IT'S BEEN SAID BUT I ALSO
APPRECIATE THE- THOSE- CULPRITS
THOSE WHO HAVE ABUSED THIS THAT
AND THE AND I THINK WE NEED TO
SEE MORE OF THAT ENFORCEMENT.
BUT BUT THAT IS A CHALLENGE FOR
ME AND PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
BUT I DO YOU DON'T WIN IN THE
STUDIES ON THIS THE- LITTLE.
SHOWER SHOES THAT WE SAW THE-
THEIR THIRD IT DOES SEEM TO BE
A PERVASIVE PROBLEM. AND IN
THAT FROM GOING WITH SENATOR
ROGERS IF THERE DOES SEEM TO BE
AN ISSUE HERE RELATEDTO. TO
THE COST DIFFERENTIAL THAT
COMES FROM WHAT TO EAT BUT- I
GUESS WHAT I'M NOT SEEN AND WE
HAVE THIS CERTAINLY AND I DID
LOOK THROUGH THIS A LITTLE MORE
DETAIL. LEFT THE COMPANY FROM.
BUT THE SOME OF OUR- PRODUCTS
THEY'RE NOT THE SAME MORE
SHIRTS SOME ARE ON SALE SUMMER
NOT. BUT IT WOULD BE
INTERESTING TO THERE HAVE BEEN
A- KIND OF A- IN THE- NOW. OF
LOOK AT THE. THIS IF THERE.
BEEN THIS DISC. PRETTY IT. I
MEAN THE I DON'T KNOW. HOW YOU
CAN CALL IT ANYTHING. THAT
INTER OF THE PRODUCTS THAT WE
SEEN IN AT THAT WERE BE EITHER
AND- TO BE ABLE TO. TO IDENTIFY
THE PROBLEMS AND- THEN LOOK AT
WHAT THAT MOTIVATION HAS BEEN
AND HOW IT WORKS AND THEN WE
CAN I THINK CORRECTED BECAUSE
THERE HAS TO BE A WAY. AROUND
THIS TO MEAN THE COST THE
DOLLAR THE- HELP CONSUMERS
PAIN- IS- IS OUTRAGEOUS FOR IF
YOU LOOK AT THAT FROM THE
DIFFERENCES SO HOPEFULLY WE CAN
SEE THAT THE- THE DATA. AND
THEN DETERMINE IF IT IS A
PROBLEM THAT ACTUALLY NEEDS TO
BE CORRECTED I MEAN FROM WHAT
I'VE SEEN IT IS A PROBLEM BUT
I'D BE NICE. TO HAVE SOME TO GO
BY. THE CENTER IN LET ME REFER
YOU TO THE BACKGROUND PAPER
THAT DOES SIDE A NUMBER. OF
THESE STUDIES BOTH FROM MEDIA.
AT WE HAD WHEN HERE. IN THE IS
A- THE IS. YEAH A REAL. IN IN
TO YOU KNOW WHAT IS PER. IN ITS
SINCE. AND IT ISN'T ALWAYS
OBVIOUS AGAIN WHEN WE CHOSE
REFER BACK TO THE TO TEDDY
BEARS. YOU'RE OUT WITH YOUR
GRANDKIDS AND- YOUR
GRANDDAUGHTER ONCE THAT PINK
TEDDY BEAR. AND YOU DISCOVER
THAT DID PERHAPS EVEN NEXT TO
IT IS THE BLUE TEDDY BEAR. AND
ITS TWO BUCKS MORE FOR THE PINK
WHEN YOU SAY SWEET OR LET LET'S
GET THE BLUE ONE. IT'S LESS
EXPENSIVE. THAT THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND THAT LANGUAGE
THEY'RE GOING TO SIT THERE AND
MAKE A STINK RIGHT NOW MIDDLE
OF A- OF A DEPARTMENT STORE IN.
YOUR EMBARRASSED AND YOU SAY
OKAY WILL SPEND THE EXTRA MONEY
LET'S GET HERE- THAT'S THE KIND
OF THING THAT. THAT YOU ARE
HAVE TO ASK IS A WHY IS SEN
HAPPENING. IN IN MAYBE IF I
COULD JUST IN THINKING ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE I'M GOING BACK IN
MY MEMORY OF THE BICYCLE THAT I
BOUGHT FOR MY GRANDDAUGHTER THE
PINK ONE THAT I HAD TO GET
BECAUSE IT WAS PAYING. FOR HER.
AND NOW I'M WONDERING HOW MUCH
I PAY MORE FOR THAT PROBABLY
ABOUT 13% OF IT FOR ME 13% BUT
I GUESS WHAT I'M LOOKING AT IS.
WORKING THIS IS FOR HILL. TALK
ABOUT SEXIST IN THAT COMMENT
AIDS. YOU KNOW WHAT I'M WITH MY
GRANDDAUGHTERS AND THEY WANT
SOMETHING IT DOESN'T MATTER.
WHAT IT IS I'M GOING TO BUY.
AND YOU REALLY WANT. ME TO PAY
THE ALL THE RIVER. YEAH NO BUT
MOST OF US ARE THE SAME WAY IN
THE THEN THE QUESTION BECOMES
WHY WHY DO THEY WANT PINK AND
THEN WHY IS STEPPING MORE
EXPENSIVE. THAN THINKING IF IT
WERE MY GROUP F. I HAVE
GRANDCHILDREN GRANDSONS. I MAY
LOOK AT THEM AS A- ALL RIGHT
YOU DON'T BEAT. THAT THING YOU
KNOW. YOU KNOW I. AB THAT. AND
I'M JUST FOR NOT GET THE PINK
WOULD KNOW WHAT THE BLACK WHEN
AND BLACK ONE TO BE CHEAPER
WITH THAT TRUE BUT I'VE IN
TERMS OF ME THEM EVERY THAT
THEY ME THEY KNOW THAT THE
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN BECAUSE
WE'RE GOING TO DO BUT BUILT FOR
THOUGHT IN THAT'S PART OF WHY
WE HAVE THIS DISCUSSION AND I
WANNA THANK ALL OF YOU FOR.
PARTICIPATING IN THIS- YOU KNOW
IT'S IT IS A VERY INTERESTING
ONE AGAIN THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION ISSUE WE ARE GOING TO
DISAGREE WITH THIS AND THIS THE
COURTS ARE SET UP SO THAT WE
GET THIS KIND OF FRIVOLOUS. TWO
VT THIS COULD OF. A TRYING TO
BEAR. ON PEOPLE AND EXTORT.
THAT THEY GET TAKEN CARE VERY
QUICKLY- AND WE'VE HAD. AGAIN
THIS BILL IS PART OF THE IN
RESERVE RIGHT TO ACT WHICH HAS
HAD A PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
IN IT. SINCE NINETEEN FIFTY
NINE AND E HAVEN'T SEEN THE
WORLD AND- THE COURTS EXPLODE.
I'VE HAD A PROBLEM WITH A DA- I
DON'T EQUATE THE TWO BUT IF
THERE'S SOME WAY WE CAN. SURE
EVERYONE WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT THIS THIS IS APPLES AND
ORANGES A WE'RE NOT. THAT WE'RE
NOT LOOKING A TAD ALTHOUGH-
HOPEFULLY WE'RE SEEING LESS AND
LESS ADA VIOLATIONS- OF BECAUSE
OF THAT OU KNOW YOU CAN EVEN
CALL AT SOME LEVEL OF-
INTIMIDATION SO THE PEOPLE ARE
COMPLYING WITH THE LAW. WHAT'S
INTERESTING THERE BY THE WAY.
IS A LOT OF THE QUESTIONS WELL
WHO'S RESPONSIBLE SAID THE
LANDLORD WHO RENTS OUT THE
UNITS TO PEOPLE THE- THE
BUSINESSES THEMSELVES THAT HAVE
TO DO THE BUILD OUT- IT IS
SIMPLE PROBLEM HERE WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS PRIVATE
PRICING. FRAGILE AND IS THE
BILL PROCEEDS HOPEFULLY WE'LL
WE'LL HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AND TRY TO PINPOINT. IS WHERE
THE PROBLEM LIES IN HOW THE HOW
WE CAN BEST ADDRESS IT BECAUSE
I THINK WE ALL. RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE. THERE CLEARLY HAS BEEN A
DISCRIMINATION IN PRICING AND
WHAT'S PARTICULARLY DISTRESSING
IS HOW WE'RE- BASED UPON THIS
TESTIMONY REALIZE THAT MOST OF
THE PROBLEM IS RELATIVELY NEW.
FIND OTHER WAYS YOU KNOW USED
TO BE. A HIT VOICE TORIES
DEPARTMENT AND THE GIRLS TOYS
DEPARTMENT AND THEN THERE WERE
LAWSUIT ABOUT THAT THAT THEY
COULD NO LONGER DO THAT. SO
THAT IN EVERY KIND OF GOT.
AGAIN TILL. COMPANY FIGURE OUT
A WAY THAT THEY COULD YET
AGAINST MORE MONEY OUT OF
PRODUCT FOR GIRLS AND- WOMEN.
AND HERE WE ARE TRYING TO PUT
THE HOPEFULLY PUT THE BRAKES ON
THE TO THE MEN OF OUR WOMEN
BUSINESS. A COMMUNITY OF THE
COMPANIES THAT ARE REALLY
TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT THING
WILL GET THE CHECK THE. TWENTY
CENTER WORKING AT AND- OF THE
CERTAINLY. I LOOKED TO THE CAN.
THAT A DISK. A AS WE GO FORWARD.
WE DO WANT ONE FIGHT. THEY JUST
MAKE ONE COMMENT SO SENATOR AND
REFUGES INDULGE ME FOR ONE
SECOND AND IT'S NOT ABOUT THE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION BUT- I
THINK IT'S AN INTERESTING LIKE
PERSONAL CHOICE AND I'VE BEEN
AND NOW SINCE THIS ISSUE HAS
BEEN WHEN YOU'RE IN A RETAIL
LOCATION TO KIND OF DO YOUR OWN
ANALYSIS EVEN GOOGLE ON OUR
ONLINE RETAILERS AND KIND OF
COMPARE PRODUCTS BECAUSE- I
THINK THAT IS- A- IN A WAY TO
KIND OF INVESTIGATE THIS EVEN
FURTHER AND TO FIND CERTAIN
PRODUCTS AND LOOK TO SEE WHAT
THE PINK ONE IS VERSUS HE
OTHER COLORS. TO DO YOUR OWN
SELF ANALYSIS OF THIS ISSUES-
WHEN YOU'RE STUDYING IT I THINK
IT'S HELPFUL I AGREE
UNFORTUNATELY THE PROBLEM I'LL
GET TO INTEREST IN IS I DON'T
KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE SO
MUCH TIME ON THEIR HANDS TO DO
THIS I I'VE SEEN SO MANY PEOPLE
WITH CHILDREN ZOOMING THROUGH
THE GROCERY STORE. GRAB PRADA.
THE CARD GETTING THOSE KIDS
HOME BECAUSE YOU GOT TO FEED
HIM. GOT HOME WORKING GET A
BATES YOU'VE GOT A GET TO WORK
IT'S ALMOST A LAW. BUT IT IS
SOMETHING TO THE TO THE EXTENT
THAT THERE IS THAT TIME TO. TO
BE DISCRIMINATING. OR
DISCRIMINATING SHOPPERS WHEN IT
COMES TO DISCRIMINATORY
PRACTICES THAT WOULD CERTAINLY
BE IDEAL. WAS POINDEXTER DO
CHOICES AND SO FOR THOSE OF US
INTO- MY COLLEAGUE TO. WITH THE
CHAMBER JENNIFER I'M SORRY-
MOST OF US SOME OF US WOMEN YES
WE HAVE THAT OPTION TO BE ABLE
TO PICK AND CHOOSE WHAT WE
WANT- BUT I ALSO BELIEVE THAT
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT. A
DIFFERENT DEMO. WHO MAY NOT
HAVE THAT OPTION WHO MAY NOT
HAVE THAT CHOICE. WHO MAY BE
FINANCIALLY- RIGHT STRUGGLING
YOU KNOW AN EXTRA TWO DOLLARS
HERE MAKES A DIFFERENCE SO I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR
US TO UNDERSTAND THAT WE DON'T
NEED MANUFACTURERS ARE
RETAILERS TELLING US HOW MUCH
WE CAN PAY IT WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO PAY MORE THAT'S OUR
CHOICE BUT DON'T BASE IT BASED
ON I'M A ONE MAN AND THIS IS
THE PRODUCT I SAT RIGHT HERE IN
GOOGLE CAN DAHLE. VERSES A
BARBIE DOLL. CAN WAS NINE
DOLLARS BARBIE WAS TWELVE
DOLLARS. KIDS TO DIE BARBIES A
GIRL I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH
WE'RE CLEAR WE NEED TO MAKE
THAT. THANK YOU WITH THAT DO WE
HAVE ANY PUBLIC TESTIMONY THERE
ANY PEOPLE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO WATER TO COME
ON UP HERE SIR AND- YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. IF YOU YOU FOLKS.
ARE MORE THAN WELCOME TO STAY
OR TO LEAVE A FEW. ARE ARE DONE
SIR GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES MY NAME IS
SUMIT SHAH AND I'M ACTUALLY
HERE'S A PENNY TO MISS META-
WHO OF COURSE COMING IN
SPEAKING FOR VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THAT SHE'S BEEN DOING
FOR MANY YEARS ACROSS ALL BOTH
WITH A WORK AND BOX AND WITHIN
CONGRESS- I'VE BEEN LISTENING
TO A LOT OF TESTIMONY IT'S VERY
POWERFUL INFORMATION AND WAS
SOMETHING THAT ACTUALLY THAT.
MISSOURI HAD MENTIONEDTHE
CHAMBER FROM IT AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S TAUGHT US
SPEAK SPECIFICALLY TO MY WORK
I'M IN THE VENTURE WILL ENSURE
CAPITAL WE BEST A CONSUMER
BRANDS SO BRANDS LIKE WILL BE
PARKER CUT BY BRANDS LIKE
CARRIES AND I'D LIKE TO TOUCH
ON HARRY'S FOR. EXAMPLE AS A
RAZOR START UP WHEN HER STARTED.
THE PRODUCT WAS BASED ON THE
LEVEL OF KERR. WITH JUST THE
RIGHT LEVEL OF CONVENIENCE THE
PART THAT IT JUST WORKS. BUT
THE BRAND ITSELF WAS MADE WITH
THE HIGHEST QUALITY. OF RAZOR
FROM A FACTORY IN GERMANY. BUT
THE PRICE ITSELF WAS
COMPARABLE- BESIDES THE FACT IT
WAS SELLING DIRECT TO CONSUMER
OR ONLINE- BUT WAS MULTI
ALTERNATELY DESIGNED FOR THE
LEVEL OF CONVENIENCE TO THE
CUSTOMER. THAT RELATES. TO IT.
I THINK ABOUT THE GENERAL
LEVELS OF THE CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE IT'S DESIGNED TO HELP
SMALL BUSINESSES TO WORK WITH
SMALL BUSINESSES. AND IN ITS
ABSOLUTE PURIST FORM. SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE DESIGNED WITH
THIS RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
CUSTOMER. THAT THEY SHOULD
PROVIDE. THE BEST LEVEL OF.
SERVICE THE BEST REPUTATION.
THE BEST LEVEL OF TRANSPARENCY
AND HELP TO THEIR CUSTOMERS
THEMSELVES THAT'S HOW ANY SORT
OF CUSTOMER RELATIONSHIP YOU
CAN DO. WORKS OFFLINE. AND WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT THIS LEVEL OF
PRICE DISCRIMINATION THAT.
EXISTS FROM HERE IT'S NOT JUST
SO MUCH ABOUT THE FACT THAT THE
COMPONENTS THEMSELVES. OR
SERVICES AND IT'S REALLY LAW
LOT DUE TO MARKETING AND I SAY
THIS SPECIFICALLY. AS A MEMBER
WHO'S PROCEDURES OVER THE PAST
ELEVEN YEARS OF MY CAREER- BUT
ALSO THAT THE COMPONENTS
THEMSELVES ACROSS NO MATTER
WHAT GENDER. ARE BASICALLY THE
SAME. WE TALK ABOUT COLOGNE SO
WE TALK ABOUT- FRAGRANCES THOSE
PRODUCTS THEMSELVES THOSE
COMPONENTS ARE ACTUALLY THE
SAME. AND IT REALLY IS ON A
DIFFERENT OKAY OF PACKAGING
IT'S A COMMODITIZED WORLD. THE
OTHER STORY FOR ANOTHER TIME.
BUT I JUST THINK THIS AND CLOSE
FROM THIS LEVEL WHERE.
RELATIONSHIPS MATTER RIGHT YOU
ARE REPRESENTING SMALL
BUSINESSES. PRESENTING THESE
MODERN POP SHOPS AND SPACES.
THAT MORE. THAN NOT DON'T HAVE
A LOT OF CA. OF THE PRODUCTS OF
THE LOCK MANUFACTURERS. A
COMPLIMENT BUT THIS IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY. FOR YOUR
CONSTITUENTS. TO HELP AND HELP
HOLD THESE MANUFACTURERS
ACCOUNTABLE. AS BOXES BEEN
DOING. FOR THE BENEFIT OF
CONSUMERS AND FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS. THAT'S ALL. WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE PAY
THIS GUY TAKING. K. OUT OF HIS
OWN. REALLY A- AND I THINK IT
THIS THAT BE A GOOD CLOSE WILL
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION THANK
YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE THANK
YOU TO THE SPONSORS THANK YOU
TO. THE CHAMBER WILL CONTINUE
THE WORK AND THANK YOU FOR
THOSE WHO ARE LISTENING TO US.
ONWARD AND UPWARD THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE ARE ADJOURNED.